Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
grafischen ausgaben brauchen dann auch kvm wobei linux in linux mit kvm und grafik ausgaben ganz
gut geht also mit mit mit gpu passt und gedürzt ja das funktioniert erstaunlich gut aber hat wenig
anwendungszweck ja m15k da hat er recht er schreibt man braucht in der regel mehrere anläufe mit
linux warm zu werden das richtig bei mir hat es wie gesagt am anfang überhaupt nicht funktioniert
ich habe habe ich mein pk bord eigentlich laufen ok das muss ich jetzt erst noch beantworten weil
er hat schon ganz am anfang gefragt was hältst du von win klamm av wenig aber ich muss dazu
sagen es ist ganz lang her wo ich quasi das als letztes mal ausprobiert habe das ist lass mich
kein scheiß erzählen wahrscheinlich locker fünf sechs jahre her wo ich das
zuletzt ausprobiert haben und die letzten berichte die ich gelesen habe war dass das
wohl mittlerweile ganz gute erkennungsraten hat und das war es aber auch ich kann ich
kann zu viren scannern wirklich wenig sagen ich verwende ja auch außer den eingebauten
wir uns gerne wenn aus nix wenn man als natürliche mail server betreiben möchte oder der mail scannen
soll nach anderen anhänge oder falls aber dadurch scannt werden soll also warum nicht warum nicht ja
windows file server betreiben würde halt in den sammler dingen wo wo leute windows sachen drauf
hauen da würde ich wahrscheinlich auch sowas laufen lassen wobei man sagen muss dass klammer
v ist quasi im länders war profi umfeld anfühlt eigentlich absolut nicht präsent ist ich habe
noch nie irgendwo live gesehen dass jemand klammer v ein
setzt für irgendwas welchen wir uns gerne dazu ein weil ich habe gar kein ich habe ich habe den
standard windows defender fertig und er ist wenn nicht sogar besser als die meisten anderen
kommerziellen ich bin auch der meinung man braucht eigentlich gar kein während scanner
der über windows defender rausgeht doch virus total setzt unter anderem klammer vor ja gut
okay du hast recht aber wir uns total setzt gefühl wieviel 83 wir uns gerne ein
die nehmen einfach alles was da ist was ich damit meine ich habe noch keinen gesehen der irgendwo in
der serverlandschaft irgendwie im enterprise wie auch immer umfeld einen file server oder
irgendwas oder eine mail server oder irgendwas betreibt und dort zum schluss zum schutz klammer
v drauf habe ich nicht gesehen ich will nicht sagen dass es nicht gibt aber habe ich noch
nicht gesehen mit anderen viren scannen holt man sich auch ganz gerne mal lücken ein ja mit
allem also potenziell holt man sich ja mit allem lücken ein habt ihr das mitgekriegt mit dem tf2 und
cisco source code league kaspersky aber uns auf der arbeit haben wir mal eine weile kaspersky
er hatte das mitgekriegt hier dass die die haben sollte haben den source code von team photos 20
es geliebt allerdings ist das der source code der ist von der ist drei jahre alt oder so dass
der ist nix also ist nicht sonderlich sonderlich neu und ja genau das kommt auch dazu der league
an sich der ist noch nicht mal neu der ist jetzt als wieder neu aufgetaucht das problem ist das hat
ein bisschen auch ein bisschen publicity gekriegt das ganze und viele sind aufmerksam geworden für
cs ist das wohl relativ wenig problematisch für team photos 2 ist es aktuell ziemlich heftig weil
team photos 2 halt kaum veränderungen gekriegt hat in dieser zeit normalerweise muss man ja sagen rein
aus rein theoretisch gesehen macht dieser source ist also mal angenommen diese software wäre perfekt
programmiert ja dann würde dieser source code league natürlich nichts machen logischerweise
weil wenn das wenn das ding wirklich felsenfest sicher wäre da könnte man da auch mit source code
den man kennt nichts einschleusen ja da könnte man sowohl auf server seite nichts machen als auch
nicht irgendwelche sachen einschleusen in den spielkreis von anderen leuten aber nachdem er
ist natürlich weit davon entfernt ist perfekt programmiert zu sein oder ohne jegliche probleme
findet man natürlich lücken deutlich einfacher wenn man den source code kennt ja und aktuell
sagen ja alle spielt also also welf sagt team photos 2 könnt ihr spielen ist passiert überhaupt
nichts aber wenn man das sich die berichte so anguckt kann man zurzeit team photos 2 wohl
sollte man abstand halten so ist der download fertig übrigens dass ich keine fragen vergesse
ich habe ja heute mal wieder meinen mein chat mit log tool an hey max welche distribution
würdest du für unternehmen empfehlen hauptsache ui 5 was für ein ding was ist ui 5 abab
ich weiß auch nicht wie monka monka tos das ganze ist das ist die sap programmiersprache ich weiß
es nicht csgo ist bestimmt ich glaube ganze source zeug ist c++ und source und gold source also half
life 1 source war auch schon c++ ich kann es ja ich kann es ja nicht sagen also welche distribution
dafür gut geeignet ist also ich finde einsteiger
mäßig kann man ein mit linux mit nicht viel verkehrt bin ich viel verkehrt machen da hast
du so viele ressourcen zu es ist einsteiger freundlich gemacht das ist alles dabei was
man braucht und es basiert entweder auf ubuntu oder debian das heißt man auch alles was man
braucht also einsteiger mäßig finde ich ist mit so das beste was man zurzeit machen kann wenn man
wenn man sich auch vielleicht die leute nicht so gut auskennt und du kannst mit sicherheit da auch
wenn sie was für linux gibt da auch dein was ui 5
machen habe ich noch nie gemacht keine ahnung was es gibt kannst du das mit garantiert machen die
sache ist die wo ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin bei diesem ganzen büsse zeug um immer ein bisschen
aufpassen muss ist ob man nicht dort irgendwelche zertifizierten kram braucht oder ob man nur support
kriegt wenn man zertifizierten kram einsetzt dann wird wahrscheinlich kaum den weg an an
suse oder vor allem red hat oder irgendwas dabei vorbeiführen ja aber das mag sein das stimmt sowohl
Sowohl das Gentoo als auch das Arch Linux Wiki sind super.
Wartet mal.
Oh, Corona hier.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Sowohl das Gentoo Wiki als auch das Arch Linux Wiki, auch das deutsche Arch Linux Wiki, die sind alle toll.
Aber trotzdem würde ich für Einsteiger kein Arch Linux empfehlen, auch kein Manjaro, sondern die sollen erstmal mit am besten Linux Mint oder was hatten wir letztens?
Was hat mir auch gut gefallen?
Ich habe es schon wieder vergessen.
Wir haben doch letztens eins ausprobiert, was mich echt überrascht hat.
Ne, Pop!OS war es glaube ich nicht.
Pop!OS war etwas, was mir nicht gefallen hat, oder was?
Pop!OS?
Wir haben so drei, vier Sachen ausprobiert und eins davon...
Genau, also, genau, drei Sachen haben mir ganz gut gefallen.
Das China OS hat mir ganz gut gefallen, wobei ich dann sagen muss, weiß nicht, ob man das nehmen soll.
Elementary fand ich auch ziemlich gut, aber noch irgendein anderes.
Das war nicht Sorin.
Sorin hat gesackt, oder?
Ich weiß nicht.
Was hatten wir?
Sidox hatten wir noch, oder?
War das Sidox, was man so angeguckt hat, was ich auch ganz nett fand?
EWRT, Subscriber, ich habe es mal wieder nicht.
Richtigen Hackermans hier wieder am Subscriben, habe ich wieder nicht richtig gesehen.
Solos, das könnte Solos gewesen sein, ja.
Warte mal, ich muss erstmal hier...
Ach, guck mal, man kann sogar Suse auswählen hier.
Suse Linux 64, Wahnsinn.
Nicht, dass das hier nicht viel großen Unterschied machen wird, oder so.
Das machen wir nicht hier.
Das machen wir auf...
Wo haben wir hier?
E.
Machen wir OpenSuse-Test, dass ich ihn nachher wieder finde zum Wegschmeißen.
Machen wir.
Komm, drei.
Drei CPUs kriegt er.
Und kriegt er mal...
Wie viel RAM geben wir dir erstmal?
4096 soll erstmal reichen.
4G.
Hanat, weiter.
Weiter.
New Disk.
60G.
Single File.
Next.
Customize Hardware.
Wir schmeißen wie immer den Printer raus.
Den Rest lassen wir dran.
Close.
Finish.
So.
So, genau.
Irgendwas wollte ich gerade noch beantworten aus dem Chat.
Also, Ivioti, danke schön für den Sub.
Hyper Subscriber.
Ähm...
Herz93 schreibt, in den meisten Spielen ist die Sharp benutzt, oder?
Mittlerweile ist die Sharp relativ verbreitet, dank Unity.
Aber Spieleprogrammierung dürfte immer noch C++ dominiert sein.
Leider.
Ihr wisst ja, dass ich C++ für die abgrundtief beschissenste Sprache überhaupt halte.
Welche Antivirenlösung läuft eigentlich auf macOS?
Oder gibt es da gar nichts?
Kein Schimmer.
Zumal es ja sogar für Android- und Mobile-Sachen mittlerweile Antivirus-Zeug gibt,
weil die Geld verdienen wollen, bin ich mir sicher.
Da gibt es bestimmt auch irgendwas für macOS.
EA hat angekündigt, dass Battlefield 5 noch ein Feature-Update kommt,
und danach kommt nichts mehr.
Ja, hoffentlich kommt bald mal ein neues Battlefield raus, was was taugt.
Please.
Äh.
Hexort mal los bei DICE.
Oder am besten nicht bei DICE, sondern bei irgendjemand, der ein ordentliches Battlefield macht.
Also sprich, die, die alle von DICE abgehauen sind, sollen mal ein ordentliches Battlefield zusammen machen.
So.
Äh.
ISO.
Downloads.
Da ist es.
Wie gesagt, ich habe seit 20 Jahren keinen SUSE mehr installiert.
Ich habe keine Schimmer, wirklich absolut keinen Schimmer, was mich, was mich erwartet.
Eine Glühbirne.
Okay, wir machen erstmal wieder Fullscreen.
Und ich bin mal gespannt, ob es OpenSUSE schafft, ähm, FireWare-Tools standardmäßig zu installieren.
Wir hatten ja bisher, glaube ich, nur die China, nur das China-Linux und, und, und, und, und, das neue Ubuntu 2004.
Die hatten es auch geschafft.
Die haben jetzt auch, äh, FireWare-Tools standardmäßig dabei.
Ja.
Äh, ich sehe gerade, war es M15.
Da muss ich ihm recht geben.
Er schreibt, äh, aber ist schon krass, wie sich das mit der Zeit entwickelt hat.
Am Anfang musste man Windows-WLAN-Treiber rappen und mittlerweile funktioniert 90% Out-of-Box mitunter besser als Windows.
Ja.
Man muss sagen, dass wenn es nicht gerade was Exotisches ist oder was, wo der Hersteller gar keinen Bock drauf hat, ist es unter Linux mit der Treiber-Unterstützung relativ gut.
Also die funktionieren halt einfach.
Die sind, die sind halt direkt da.
Du musst nicht installieren.
Die funktionieren einfach.
Und auch ein bisschen abgedrehtere Sachen wie Multifunktion.
Multifunktionsdrucker und sowas sind meistens relativ gut.
Wenn nicht, gibt es meistens relativ einfach Abhilfe.
Oder aber es sind Geräte, wo die Hersteller gar keinen Bock drauf haben und dann hast du halt einfach gelitten.
Das ist dann halt so der, der, so der Riesensprung von, zwischen Windows und Linux.
Dass vieles Out-of-the-Box halt richtig gut funktioniert.
Aber wenn es halt gar nicht geht, dann geht es halt meistens so mit riesem Aufwand.
Guckt euch mal an, was es für ein, für ein scheiß Riesen-Act ist.
Ähm, Hardware-Decoding.
Zu kriegen im Browser unter Linux.
Das ist ja so pauschal gar nicht möglich.
In dem Umfang wie unter Windows.
Fehlen immer Sachen.
Aber das stimmt schon.
Am Anfang war es witzig mit WLAN-Treibern.
Da musste man noch diesen Endiswrapper, hieß das Ding, ne?
Ne?
Kennst du den noch MK15?
Ne, M15K.
Kennst du den noch hier?
Hört sich nämlich so an, dass hast du ja auch den alten Kram schon mitgemacht damals.
Wie alt bist du?
Ich bin 35.
Ich habe, ich bin 35.
Ich habe gedacht, ich bin 1984 geboren.
QuickMuffs.
Ich hatte dieses Jahr noch keinen Geburtstag.
Ich bin 35.
Monka Old.
Most popular programming languages.
Das haben wir schon geguckt, oder?
Das haben wir schon geguckt.
Hat eigentlich irgendwer mal angefangen ein Trinkspiel zu machen, jedes Mal, wenn du was gegen C++ hast.
Ähm, das ist glaube ich keine so gute Idee, weil da bist du wahrscheinlich schon nach einer halben Stunde Stream besoffen.
Ne, ne, ne, Reket.
Äh, ne.
Reketi, Reket.
So einfach ist das nicht.
Das geht nur, erstens, wenn du die richtige Grafikkarte hast.
Ähm, und zweitens, auch nicht mit allen Videoformaten.
Ich sag ja, das geht nicht richtig.
Also, zum Beispiel, VP9 ist schon mal gar nicht.
VP8, VP9.
Hardwarebeschleunigung ist schon mal gar nicht, auch wenn das die Grafikkarte kann.
Und ich glaube, richtig gut funktioniert der Kram aktuell eh nur mit Intel.
Und teilweise Nvidia.
Also so easy ist das nicht.
Es ist gut, dass es das User Repo gibt, dass man das relativ einfach hinkriegt, wenn es unterstützt wird.
Aber das hat so viele Krankheiten, Hardware Accelerated oder Hardware Decoding.
Ähm, ist eklig.
So, also wir starten mal die Installation.
Boot vom Hardtest, haben wir nicht.
Upgrade, more, was steckt hinter more?
Boot Linux, ne, haben wir nicht.
Wir kommen wieder zurück.
Okay.
Escape? Ah, yes.
Okay, ohne Scheiß, Leute.
Der Installer sieht aus wie 1999.
Also, dieses, auch dieser Ladebalken und so.
Der sieht aus wie 1999.
Oh, das ist ja noch der Oldschool.
Das ist ja noch der Oldschool Fedora Starter hier.
Oder der Oldschool Red Hat Starter, muss man ja eher sagen.
Ich bin mir egal.
Leute, weiß irgendjemand, ob ein aktuelles Fedora oder Red Hat überhaupt noch
diesen, diesen, diesen, diesen Starter verwendet?
Ich meine, wir haben zwar auf der Arbeit komplett Red Hat auf allen Servern,
aber ich gucke denen nie beim Booten zu.
Und aktuelles Fedora habe ich auch schon Jahre nicht installiert.
Ich habe ja immer auf dem Desktop, wisst ihr ja,
ich habe mein Manjaro auf dem Desktop, auch auf der Arbeit.
Und auf meinen privaten Servern Ubuntu und halt CentOS auf den Kisten auf der Arbeit.
Aber ich sehe die Dinger nie booten.
Als Fallback, okay.
Pepehacks.
So, während er installiert.
Ah ja, Lizenz Agreement.
Excellent, alles klar.
Also man muss ja mal sagen, im Vergleich zu Windows ist die Lizenzbedingung doch ziemlich kurz.
Keyboard Layout.
No Dead Keys will ich haben.
Ja, wunderbar.
Language, US, sehr schön.
Die Musik kommt mir bekannt vor.
Das ist, das ist Mario Galaxy, oder?
Ja.
Kann es sein, dass die Musik übelst schwankt in der Lautstärke?
Also meist die, meist die Musik in diesem Mix hier übelst laut und mal leise.
Ähm, was?
Du hörst nichts.
Ja, das liegt daran, weil die, weil die Playlist irgendwie unterschiedlich laut ist.
Vielleicht sollte ich auch mal so einen Kompressor-Effekt auf die Browser-Playlist machen für die Musik,
dass die immer gleich laut ist.
Oh, heftige Seitenarbeit.
Ah, die Romani Ranch.
Die, die, die.
Oder besser gesagt auch die Dings hier, wie heißt die, London, London Ranch.
So.
Okay, Lizenz-Agreement, wunderbar, so.
Äh, wie ich so schnell wechsle, irgendjemand hat gefragt, ich seh's gar nicht mehr, wie ich so schnell wechsle zwischen Windows und VMs.
Ganz einfach, ähm, mit Windows-Taste und Steuerung.
Man hatte hier mehrere Desktops.
Und die kann man durchwechseln mit, ähm, Windows-Taste und Pfeiltasten.
Und bei mir ist halt einfach auf dem zweiten Desktop im Vollbild, ähm, Virtual, äh, nicht Virtual, vor allem bei Workstation.
So, wir stimmen zu.
Ah, welcome.
Oh, jetzt kommt Just.
Active Network Connection.
Ja, hau rein.
Ähm, Main.
Na gut, Sources brauchen wir jetzt nicht, ich will nix kompilieren.
Na komm, scheiß drauf.
Mach mal, hau, hau alles rein.
Ähm, next.
So, während das installiert, mach ich noch mal, gucken wir uns noch mal ein paar Fragen an, dass ich nicht wieder alles vergesse diesmal.
Ähm, also, wie alt hatten wir?
Ähm, also, ich würde das, ich würde das machen, die Sache ist die, ich glaube, das ist MonkaTOS.
Zumindest mal so kurz reingucken würde ich, aber ich glaube, das ist MonkaTOS.
Ich würde das vielleicht machen, wenn irgendjemand den Source-Code auf GitHub mal irgendwann lädt.
Und man quasi abstreiten kann, dass man weiß, dass das aus illegalen Quellen kommt.
Dann würde ich das vielleicht mal machen.
Aber, äh, sonst eher nicht.
Zumal man auch sagen muss, das ist mit Sicherheit sehr umfangreich.
Und man kann dann nur exemplarisch mal reingucken.
Und sich vielleicht über ein paar C++ Sachen lustig machen.
Und, ähm, dann wieder zumachen.
Ist das auf GitHub? Ernsthaft?
Haha, okay, Moment.
Haha.
Äh, im Gurlap-Artikel.
Hier, da war es doch, Quelltexte.
GitHub.
Hahaha, witzig.
Ah, das ist, das ist, das ist der CS.
Der CS-Source-Code. Ist der Team Fortress-Source-Code auch?
Da irgendwo?
Golem gibt es wirklich noch, ja?
Boah, la...
This is posted for educational purposes. Ja.
Okay, aber allein schon hier durchzublicken ist halt, ist halt heftig, ja? Also...
Was zum Teufel soll denn da Public sein?
Counter-Strike 1.5.
Ist 1.5 nicht...
League of League of CS-Code-Source.
Okay.
Tja, wo können... Engine, DS, Filesystem, Game. Game. Game klingt gut.
Client.
Und das Server dürfte ein bisschen weniger sein, hoffe ich mal.
Es ist C++, so viel ist schon mal sicher.
Das Base-Prop-Door.
Achso, das ist ein Header. Den Header juckt uns jetzt nicht, wir brauchen mal irgendwas.
Das sieht relativ ordentlich aus alles, muss man ja mal sagen, ja?
Also das kann man schon, kann man schon durchblicken.
Der Umut hat subscribt.
Zwei Monate, dankeschön, huge sub.
Und hat davor gefragt, äh, ich darf mich jetzt auch mit Vodafone rumschlagen?
Ah, nice.
Excellent.
Ähm...
Die geben mir 20% meiner Leistung, die ich gebucht habe.
Kennst du einen Trick, wie ich da mehr aufmerksam werde?
Du kannst den Twitter-Support vollspammen.
So, wo ist denn mal hier was Interessantes?
Wo kann man denn hier mal gucken?
AI Pathfinding.
Die haben Bots?
Ja klar, die haben, natürlich haben die Bots.
Jetzt, stimmt, klar haben die Bots.
Wo ist der Friseur?
Äh, aktuell dank Corona nicht frisieren.
Ähm, der spielt komische Handy-Games.
Äh, wie wird bei so großen Spielen und Unternehmen Überblick über die Programme Spiele behalten?
Äh, viel Erfahrung und eine ganz gute Struktur.
Ich würde mal sagen, so rein für jemand, der das bis zum ersten Mal sieht, wirkt das doch recht strukturiert, ne?
Wobei man halt sagen muss, das ist halt auch so ein typisches C++-Ding, das artet immer massiv aus.
Guck mal, das hier ist eine Datei mit fast 2300 Zeilen Code für Bot-Wegfindung anscheinend, ja?
Und das ist bei weitem ja noch nicht alles.
Hier sieht man den ganzen anderen Kram noch.
Und es ist echt ordentlich auf den ersten Blick programmiert, so wie das aussieht.
Die machen auch glücklicherweise, und eins finde ich cool, ähm, Twitter Support hilft doch nur, wenn man viele Follower hat.
Nee, es ist bestimmt nicht von Vorteil, es ist bestimmt nicht von Nachteil, aber ähm, die helfen dir auch so.
Also was ich gut finde, das erste, was mir hier ins Auge gesprungen ist, dass sie die ganzen Sachen ausschreiben.
Das ist so eine, das ist so eine Angewohnheit, die viele C-, vor allem C-Programmierer haben, dass sie alles abkürzen.
Also sprich, da wird dann, da wird dann aus, keine Ahnung, link, move type bytes, wird dann i underscore mtbs oder so.
So.
Das ist, das wäre so eine, das wäre so eine typische, äh, so eine typische C++, so eine typische C-Variable.
I underscore mtbs.
I mtbs gleich null.
Oder sie denken, what?
Fix me 2002.
Ja, das.
Sachen, die funktionieren, werden nie gefixt.
Is power of two.
Oh, ex, excellent.
Das ist gut.
Die nennen den Kram so, wie es macht, da blickt man wenigstens durch.
Äh, denkst du, dass sich die Entwicklung auf einzelne Teams aufteilt?
Also ein Team macht nur Bots, die anderen Performance.
Na, auf der Ebene wird, auf der Ebene glaube ich eher nicht.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass die ein Team haben, was nur Bots macht.
Nein, ein Team, was, ähm, nur Performance optimiert.
Ähm, ich denke schon, dass die unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte haben.
Was geht jetzt, was geht mir mit der Musik auf einmal ab?
Jetzt wieder viel zu laut.
Das klingt zu französisch.
Ähm, ja, oder so, ich, ich denke das schon, dass die unterschiedliche Schwerpunkte haben.
Ähm, aber dass die einzelnen Teams für Bots, einzelnen Teams für Performance haben, das glaube ich eher nicht.
Das hört sich echt sehr Baguette-mäßig an, die Musik.
Das sind irgendwelche, das sind irgendwelche Debugging-Geschichten.
So nach dem Motto, wenn der, äh, AI-Performance-Monitor aktiviert ist, irgendwelche Debug-Geschichten, dann, das ist so eine, das ist so eine typische C, C, beziehungsweise C++, äh, Benahmung.
M, Underscore, N, Perf, Stat, BP, Punkbuster vielleicht?
Nee, Punkbuster glaube ich nicht.
Vor allem nicht im Debug-Kontext.
Ähm, Member? Keine Ahnung.
M, N, Perf, Stat, PB++.
War, kann schon mal was machen. Ähm.
Das ist, das ist eine, irgendeine Debug-Geschichte.
Also Debug-Bild oder irgendwelche, äh, Debug-Defines gesetzt, dass man irgendwas nachgucken kann, wie viele, wie viele Aufrufe hier bei den Bots passieren, dass es keine Performance-Probleme gibt, was weiß ich, was auch immer.
So, und dass man hier durchblickt, muss man eh ein bisschen, ein bisschen Ahnung von der Codebase haben, sonst funktioniert das überhaupt nicht, ja.
Weil, mag noch so, mag noch so logisch klingen, aber jemand, der zum ersten Mal drin ist, hat kein Schimmer was.
Get Outer, Get Navigator, Movement Coast, so genau macht.
Man kann, man kann sich das, man kann sich das ein bisschen, ein bisschen zusammenreimen, dass der hier irgendwie versucht rauszubekommen, quasi was der, der, der beste Weg ist, den ein Bot nehmen sollte.
Aber pfff.
Task Expensive.
So, gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal in den Client rein.
Shared, Shared ist auch immer.
Portal, Steam, Portal 2.
Ist auch Portal 2 da.
Ah, die haben ein paar Sachen aus Portal 2 rübergestelzt.
In CS, gut.
Huge.
Wie schlimm ist so ein Code League eigentlich einzuschätzen?
Naja, aber das Game, wenn das ein Code League ist, von wann?
2000...
Wann wurde das gelegt? 2018 oder so?
Irgendwann, keine Ahnung.
Und es ein Ding ist, was Active Maintained ist und schon ziemlich viele grundlegende Umbauten hatte.
Pff, ich würd's jetzt...
Ist mir ganz schwer einschätzen.
Aber so Bauchgefühl sagt mir es, dass das jetzt nicht so...
...ich so wild ist.
Ich mein, das ist, das ist, das ist schwierig zu sagen.
Also, der Fehler steckt ja oftmals im Detail.
Das heißt, wenn, ähm, da jetzt irgendwelche findigen Hexor-Leute Sachen rausfinden, die immer noch im Spiel drinne sind, die man halt einfacher rausfindet, weil man den Source Code lesen kann,
dann kann das heut immer noch Probleme machen.
Generell würd ich sagen, hat das keine Firma gerne, wenn so ein Kram geleakt wird.
Vor allem, wenn es halt so ein Money-Ding ist, wie, wie CSGO.
X...
XBOX!
MonkaS!
Ah, XboxDev, da ist natürlich nichts drinne, schonmal klar.
Sack!
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob CSGO überhaupt noch auf Xbox läuft.
Jawoll, eine Tür.
So sieht ne Tür aus.
So sieht ne Tür aus in CS.
Oh, Death CPP.
Was passiert, wenn man stirbt?
Ja.
Death Notice.
Also, ich glaube, bis man da wirklich durchblickt, muss man sich das mal ne ganze Weile angeguckt haben.
Set Paint Background Enabled.
Hört sich an, wie ne Windows-Funktion irgendwie.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es ne Windows-Funktion ist.
Ne, das ist irgendeine Stil-, irgendeine Source-Geschichte.
Aber hört sich ein bisschen an, wie ne Windows-Funktion.
Moin moin, gibt's hier jetzt hier Linux-Stells?
Ja.
Wir gucken uns gerade nur nebenbei, während das installiert, mal gucken, wie weit das
ist, den, ein bisschen den CS Source Code League an.
Ah, hier.
Jetzt können wir auswählen, was wir installieren wollen.
Also, was wollen wir denn haben?
Desktop mit KDE Plasma.
Desktop mit GNOME.
Desktop mit XFCE.
Wir nehmen mal Desktop mit KDE.
Wann wurde das geleakt?
2018.
Könntest du nochmal auf die YouTube-Playlist gehen?
Das ist keine Playlist.
Das ist, ähm, einfach ein ewig langes Video mit, äh, Top 1000 Nintendo Songs.
Ohne alles?
Ne, ne, das machen wir nicht.
Ich hab, ich hab kein Schimmer, wie man OpenSUSE überhaupt einrichtet.
Mit welchen?
Was für?
Früher war's Zypper.
Das kann ich, das blick ich nicht durch.
Ähm.
Wir installieren mal KDE.
Allein schon aus dem Grund, weil ich, glaube ich, noch nie nen KDE im Stream hatte.
Und auch selbst schon Jahre kein KDE mehr verwendet hab.
Äh, so alt ein Dude, so alt ist KDE auch nicht.
Die haben ja laufend neue Updates.
Also, alles in allem, muss ich sagen, sieht wahrscheinlich KDE immer noch am besten aus.
Ja, mach mal.
Was?
BTR?
Wow!
Das sind ja die einzigen, die ich kenne, die das als Standard-Dateisystem verwenden.
Hab ich schon lange nicht mehr gesehen.
Red Hat hat keinen Bock mehr auf BTRFS.
Gibt's ja auch wieder, ähm, zig unterschiedliche Aussprachen, ja?
Man kann so den, den Noob-Style machen wie ich.
BTRFS.
Dann gibt's hier Leute, die sagen ButterFS.
Dann gibt's, dann gibt's noch BetterFS.
Ähm.
Ach, gibt's zig Aussprachen.
Viele steigen inzwischen auf BTRFS um.
Hab ich, äh, so nicht mitbekommen, dass das passiert.
Der, der Trend bei File-Systemen unter Linux ist sogar eher so, dass viele mittlerweile
mit ZFS anrücken.
Aber, dass Leute jetzt immer wieder, äh, mit ZFS anrücken, ist, äh, ist, äh, äh,
dass, dass sich gerade BTRFS großartig verbreiten würde, deckt sich zumindest nicht mit dem,
was ich so gesehen hab in letzter Zeit.
Aber das heißt nicht, dass das doch sein kann.
Achso, ja, aber KDE, genau, KDE war Standard bei OpenSUSE.
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen KDE und GNOME?
Ähm.
Also, der grundlegende Unterschied zwischen KDE und GNOME ist, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm,
ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm, ähm,
Also, der grundlegende Unterschied würde ich sagen, dass, KDE, eher darauf ausgelegt
ist, viele Optionen zu bieten und customized zu sein.
Und GNOME besser so out of box.
Ist.
Mit ziemlich, einer ziemlich genauen Vorstellung, wie man es bedienen kann.
So, und die...
Vom Unterbau her ist es natürlich auch komplett unterschiedlich.
Äh, GNOME ist zum größten Teil GTK und GTK ist GNOME.
Ich weiß, dass man
mit GTK auch andere Sachen machen kann, aber
GTK wird ganz klar
getrieben von der Gnome-Entwicklung
und von nichts anderem.
Da sieht man auch,
wie kümmerlich der Windows-Support ist bei
GTK. Es ist nicht so, dass GTK
nicht prinzipiell unter Windows läuft,
aber keiner noch irgendwie bei Verstand
es macht unter Windows was mit GTK.
Und die, die es
gemacht haben, zum Beispiel
glaube
Wireshark,
Pigeon,
VLC, die sind glaube ich
mittlerweile alle auf Qt.
Also sprich dem,
was unter KDE ist. Wobei die
Qt-Entwicklung und die KDE-Entwicklung halt komplett
getrennt sind.
Qt verwendet, äh KDE verwendet
Qt, aber die ist nicht ein und dasselbe.
Wohingegen GTK und Gnome
ziemlich eng miteinander verheiratet sind.
Qt-Entwicklung,
äh, okay, wir lassen
einfach mal Default. Next.
Just 2 Synchronized
NTP-Server.
Da haben wir sogar wenigstens die richtige Uhrzeit.
POC-Rs.
Das sieht ja wirklich noch aus wie
1999.
Nee, eher nach Casablanca will ich jetzt nicht.
Ich will eigentlich... Nein!
Hier. Ah.
Nee.
Nein.
Hier gibt's... Ah, Germany.
Geografie.
Huge.
Okay, hier macht man es nach Ländern und nicht
nach Städten.
Das ist auch komplett unterschiedlich zu diesem Stand,
dieser Standard-Linux, diesem Standard-
äh, Time-Zeitzonen-Dialog,
wo du da normalerweise auswählen
musst, äh, Berlin oder Amsterdam
oder sowas. Jetzt kommen die Leute
im Chat wieder. Max, Geografie
ist aber nicht so deins.
Müssen sie wieder
zeigen, dass sie es voll drauf haben.
Hardware-Clock set to UTC.
Ja.
Meinetwegen.
Next. Full
Username. Qt.
Chat.
Passwort. 123456.
123456.
Automatic Login.
Nee, machen wir nicht.
Ich will mal sehen, was die für ein
Login-Fenster haben.
Next.
Passwort ist zu simpel. Really used. Yes.
Natürlich.
Oh, guck mal, die haben schon die ganzen
äh, Specter und
äh, wie hieß der andere
Kram? Specter Meltdown. Specter
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, äh,
äh, Zombie Specter und was es da nicht
alles gab, haben sie schon drinnen.
Auto. Huge.
Okay.
Okay, wir machen einfach weiter.
Ja, yes, excellent.
Düdüdüdü.
Also ich muss sagen, der
Installer erinnert mich wirklich noch hart an
das, wie das 1999 oder 2001
ausgeschaut hat. Ein bisschen
schöner schon hier mit der Sidebar und so.
Aber ich finde, so ein großer
Unterschied ist da nicht dazwischen.
Ubuntu 20.04 ist
eben released. Oh. Ähm.
Gut, neu angucken
müssen wir uns. Wir haben uns die Beta schon angeguckt.
Das reicht. Äh, aber ich muss meine
Kisten updaten dann.
Weil ich wollte ja ein LTS, aber ich hab halt
das letzte installiert, was kein LTS ist.
Und jetzt, jetzt hab ich ein LTS. Da kann jetzt die nächsten paar Jahre
drauf bleiben. Äh,
Tribunen420 fragt,
Hey Max, ich bin gerade unterwegs
und kann den Stream nicht hören. Äh,
okay, dann ist es schwierig, wenn ich jetzt da drauf antworte,
oder? Ich wollte dich fragen,
wie deine Text-to-Speech-Software heißt.
Also diese koreanische Seite.
Guck mir später das Wort an. Danke
für die Antwort. Ähm, hat vorhin
jemand im Chat gepostet, voicetext.jp
war das, glaube ich.
Man muss doch nicht Ubuntu neu installieren.
Also meine Kisten
werden immer geupgradet.
Aber in der Regel upgradee ich ja auch
von LTS zu LTS.
Ich installiere da nichts neu.
Auf meinen Serverkisten will ich
kein Rolling Release haben. Das ist, finde ich,
ist Ubuntu super. Außerdem
finde ich's insofern ganz nett,
weil auf der Arbeit haben wir nur CentOS.
Und CentOS
ist echt nicht so, pff,
tja, irgendwie nicht meins, ja.
Ich mein, es ist jetzt nicht so,
dass man da überhaupt nicht mit zurecht kommt. Der Unterschied
ist nicht groß. Aber mir gefällt
irgendwie der, der Ubuntu
Way mal vielen Sachen besser.
Bis auf, und das muss ich jetzt echt sagen,
bis auf diese Netplan-Geschichte.
Das ist mega
ein Arsch.
Netplan.
Das ist diese
Netzwerk-Config-Jammel.
Wer sich das bei Canonical wieder ausgedacht hat,
der ist wahrscheinlich auch beim C++-Standard-Gremium
drinne und raucht bei regelmäßigen
C++-Meetings
irgendwelche neuen Syntax-Dinger.
Spritzt sich irgendwelche Sachen und denkt sich
dann irgendwelche neuen Syntax-Dinger aus.
Das sind bestimmt die gleichen Leute, die das machen.
Also, das würde einfach so passen,
dass Leute, die im C++-Gremium
die Sachen verbrechen, auch dafür verantwortlich
sind, dass man in Ubuntu per
YAML-Datei sein Netzwerk konfigurieren soll.
Das ist so die gleiche
gleiche Art Leute,
glaube ich, die sich sowas ausdenken.
CentOS ist nicht wild.
Es ist auf jeden Fall gut, sich auszukennen
ähm
mit der ganzen
Red Hat-Geschichte, dass man so grob weiß,
wie man da Sachen einrichtet und macht und tut und guckt.
Weil
Red Hat ist halt das Linux schlechthin
in der Enterprise-Welt. Da gibt's nix
anderes. Es gibt Red Hat und es gibt Red Hat.
Vielleicht gibt's noch Red Hat.
Ähm
Schau mal Solaris instead. Ja!
Aber
vor...
Das ist doch gar nicht so lang her. Vor
zwei Jahren oder so.
Und zwar
ich wollte mal
ich wollte irgendein ZFS-Feature
mir angucken und
da hab ich
Solaris instead, also VM.
Ja, wohlgemerkt. Nicht auf Hardware.
Ich hab Solaris installiert und
ähm
dann diese...
nach dem Tutorial das Web GUI für
für zum NAS konfigurieren
und so noch drauf gehauen.
Das war was, ey!
Schaust du dir auch mal Nixos an?
Ist Nixos nicht dieses Container OS?
Das schreib ich mir mal auf.
Das ist das Container OS, oder?
Ja, das ist das, oder?
Ja, das ist das.
Relativ sicher ist es das.
Freaky Pole Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön. Huge Sub.
High IQ Sub.
Der Kommentator
schreibt, ich rauch auch immer sonntags.
Hab ich grad gesagt, die rauchen sonntags?
Ja, ich wollt wahrscheinlich einfach nur mich ein bisschen über das
T++ Gremium wieder
ablästern. Da kommen manchmal nicht ganz so
sinnvolle Sätze bei raus.
Aber ich hab dann mit Solaris nicht wirklich
was gemacht. Ich hab das...
die eingebaute ZFS Encryption
mal ausprobiert mit dieser Oberfläche
und dann war wieder gut.
Aber Solaris,
das bringt sehr viele
gestörte Leute hervor.
Weil wir haben uns mal auf der Arbeit einen Experten
gekauft, eingekauft für
Solaris. Wir haben uns
überlegt, damals, das war ja wieder so
ein komischer Schnellschuss
von unseren
damaligen BWL Management
Leuten. Die haben gesagt, man
könnte doch unser...
man könnte doch unsere
E-Mails auf
ZFS lagern.
Dann haben sie sich den ZFS Experte,
Solaris ZFS Experte bestellt
und
als der dann da war,
der war dann eingekauft für ein halbes Jahr
und als der dann da war,
ist ihnen eingefallen, sie wollen doch
kein ZFS haben.
Also Massive Big Brain Logik.
Ist ja gut Musik.
So, und wie gesagt,
als der da war, ist ihnen dann eingefallen, sie wollen doch keine
ZFS haben.
Und dann
und dann musste
der Typ irgendwelche
Puppet Server Konfiguration
machen, obwohl er
sag mal so, wenn du Solaris kannst, kriegst du
Linux auch ein bisschen gebacken, aber
das war überhaupt nicht seine Welt, was der da macht.
Vor allem, weil Tools sind nicht installiert.
Was der da machen sollte, das war überhaupt nicht
seine Welt.
Und
der ist komplett abgedreht.
Der hat sich sein Rechner,
so eingestellt irgendwann, ich vermute mal, dass er
nicht einschläft, dass wenn er
mit dem Gesetz, Leute, es ist
legit, es ist kein Witz, ich weiß, es hört
sich bescheuert an, aber das ist wirklich so passiert.
Der hat sich sein Rechner so eingerichtet,
dass
er, wenn er mit dem Mauszeiger
an den Rand gekommen ist, an den Rand vom Bildschirm,
dann ist der PC-Speaker
hat gesummt.
Also sprich, der ist dann mit dem Maus...
Ich weiß, das klingt bescheuert, aber
es war so, ja.
Der ist dann mit dem Mauszeiger an den
Rand vom Bildschirm gekommen und da hat er
den PC-Speaker...
Das ist so dämlich, ich weiß.
Da hat er den PC-Speaker angefangen...
Und ich bin mir sicher,
der hat das absichtlich eingestellt.
Ich kenne nichts, wo das Default ist, nichts.
Und natürlich wollte der nicht,
dass wir denken, er ist
verrückt, ja. Und da hat er das dann
immer auf seinen Gnome-Desktop geschoben.
Dass das...
Dass das Gnome-Desktop irgendwie
eingerichtet hätte. Und...
Und das lief dann ungefähr so.
Du hast... Der hing da halt
auf halb acht, wahrscheinlich war er kurz vorm Einschlafen.
Ist dann mit der Maus an den Bildschirmrand gekommen.
Da hat er dann da gesagt...
Und daraufhin hat er dann immer gesagt...
Ah, der scheiß Gnome.
Der scheiß Gnome.
Oh, es laggt?
Oh, Leute. Hat's
gelaggt? Oder geht's wieder?
Ne, hat nicht gelaggt.
Ne, wie gesagt, der ist dann
immer mit der Maus an den Rand gekommen und hat jedes Mal
gesagt, der scheiß Gnome.
Der scheiß Gnome.
Der Typ hat den übelsten Schlagwerk gehabt.
Und außerdem...
Hat er gerne... Hat er gerne
Ruby... Ruby-Skripte gemacht.
Und...
Der Kerl hatte echt einen Knall. Das lief dann wirklich
ungefähr so. Der ist mit der... Der ist mit der Maus...
Mit der Maus an den... An den Bildschirmrand
gekommen. Dann hat der PC-Speaker erstmal
ein bisschen gemacht...
Dann hat er gesagt, der scheiß Gnome.
Und... Und wenn man dann sich zu ihm
umgedreht hat, hat er manchmal noch gesagt,
Ruby.
Der Typ hatte echt den übelsten Knall.
Ich wollte nicht...
Ruby.
Der war echt schon ganz dicht.
So, wer installiert mal nicht jetzt
Vmware-Tools?
Mit Jast. Früher hat man das mal mit Jast gemacht.
Ruby.
Das ist lustig, ne?
Wir hatten schon so viele externe Leute. Die sind gekommen
und gegangen. Aber manche bleiben dir...
Bleiben dir im Gedächtnis. Manche bleiben dir
im Gedächtnis, aber die meisten
krieg ich noch nicht mal. Da muss ich wirklich ganz hart
nachdenken, wer alles schon mal da gewesen ist.
Okay, wie installiert man jetzt
Open-Vmware-Tools?
Software-Management.
Okay, das sieht wirklich aus wie 1995
noch.
Hat sich nicht viel getan, ne?
Ähm, Search.
Also normalerweise heißt die Dinge ja
Open-VM-Tools irgendwie.
Wie, ist installiert?
Geht aber nicht.
Die Open-VM-Tools mögen zwar installiert sein,
aber sie funktionieren nicht.
RIP. Habe ich auch alles ausgeschaltet?
Ja.
Reboot. Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Ich reboote mal. Man weiß ja nie.
Vielleicht muss man auch... Vielleicht muss man
auch irgendwas starten.
Konsole auf... Ey, das fühlt sich echt schnell
an, die Oberfläche, ne? Aber gut, es ist auch
640x480 oder sowas.
Vmware. User.
Ähm, sind vielleicht die
Vmware-Tools nicht gestartet?
System.
CTL.
Start. Vm.
Vm-Tools. D, oder
wie heißt das Ding? Oh, ne. Vm.
Lists.
Units.
Grab-Vm.
Vm-Tools. D, habe ich doch gesagt.
Vm.
Tools. Habe ich das nicht gerade geschrieben?
Vm. Tools. D.
1.
Okay, ne.
Status.
Läuft.
Okay. Reboot. Excellent.
Äh...
Oh, Suse, jawoll.
Es erinnert
mich echt ziemlich an
Oldschool-Suse noch. So ein paar
Sachen. Auch wie das Terminal von der
Farbe her stammt, wie es sich aussieht.
Okay, also... Ah, ah, ah.
Ne. Ne.
Okay, Leute, dynamische Auflösung geht nicht.
Das ist schon mal ziemlich der Sack, dass dynamische Auflösung
nicht geht.
Obwohl Forever-Tools installiert sind.
Äh, ich muss das nicht mit... Ne, ne.
Ich muss das nicht mit System-CTL
starten, weil...
Wir haben ja gerade geguckt, es läuft.
Kernel, stimmt. Was haben wir?
Ja, das ist sogar... Das ist relativ
neu.
Das ist wirklich relativ neu. Aber das ist ja auch
die Rolling-Release-Variante von den...
Tja.
Okay, dann gucken wir mal, ob wir so Display einstellen
können. Display-Configuration.
Ah,
okay.
Ah, haha. Aber nicht die, aber
nicht die richtige Auflösung. Nur die Crap-Auflösung
kann man einstellen.
Und dann geht's auch kaputt?
Okay.
Ähm, ja.
Verstehe.
Hm.
Ähm...
Ja.
Gut, das fängt ja schon mal gut an, dass
wir die Auflösung nicht einstellen können, geschweige denn
die Forever-Tools, die laufen
diese aber nicht machen.
Vielleicht, ich hab noch eine Idee. Wir schalten noch mal aus
und erhöhen mal den RAM von der
Grafikkarte. Nicht, dass das was bringt,
aber wir können es mal probieren.
Ähm...
Moment, wo ist das hier? Display.
Wir machen doch mal
Accelerate-3D-Grafiks an. Ah,
256 MB, das reicht. Digge.
Stretch. Wir wollen
nix stretchen.
Ach, Moment, hatte ich Stretch die ganze Zeit
noch an? Hatte ich Stretch
die ganze Zeit noch an? Dann ist kein Wunder, dass
der Kram nicht funktioniert, wenn ich Stretch
noch die ganze Zeit an hatte.
Mit Stretch geht das natürlich nicht.
Dann liegt das gar nicht an OpenSUSE, sondern an
mir. Wahrscheinlich lag's an mir
und gar nicht an OpenSUSE.
Problem, ja.
Accelerate-3D lässt KDE
backen. Mach gucke.
Ah...
Excellent. Das sieht doch schon...
Ah, das sieht besser aus.
So ist das doch schön.
Also...
Es fühlt sich... Also für
VMware und
Compositing und
Gedönsverhältnisse fühlt es sich
halbwegs flüssig an.
Nicht so richtig
gut flüssig, wie auf ner
richtigen Hardware. Klar, aber es geht
halbwegs.
Da hatten wir schon deutlich Schlimmeres.
Fenster resizen?
Geht nicht.
Und mit KDE einmal klicken und doppelt klicken für...
Einmal klicken, okay.
Äh, wie ist der Shortcut zum Fenster...
Ah... Och!
Och! So, kann man nix
sagen. Was sind das denn für
abgrundtief ässliche
Buttons hier oben, äh?
Doch, bis jetzt
auch so... Ja, hier laggt's ganz schön.
Was ist der Shortcut dafür?
Muss ich jetzt tatsächlich nochmal ausprobieren.
Alt-Rechte-Maus-Taste.
Single-Click.
Ja, KDE ist ja bekannt für,
dass es sehr viele,
sehr, sehr viele
Optionen hat. Ich weiß gar nicht,
wie ich überhaupt den Single-Click
ausstellen würde.
Window-Management?
Workspace-Behaviour?
Ah! Double-Click.
Apply.
Ah, gut.
Also KDE ist halt im Vergleich
zu Gnome wirklich so ein...
Das, das, das Options...
Das Options, äh...
Overkill schlechthin. Guckt euch mal die Settings
nur von dem Terminal-Programm an.
Oh, das ist weniger geworden als
früher. Oder sag mal sowas, das ist weniger als früher.
Übersichtlicher als früher.
Oder ist...
Oder ist das einfach nur so ein
Minimode und ich kann auch den Advanced-Mode
irgendwo einschalten.
Ich glaube, die haben's einfach nur deutlich
übersichtlicher gemacht als früher.
Früher war nämlich auch...
Allein schon, wenn du die Konsole aufgemacht hast,
ähm, hast du hier
zwei Stinger Optionen voll gehabt.
Okay, erstmal gucke...
Ah! Oh, und das verwirrt
mich, dass es alt ist.
Okay, wie installiert man auf der Commando-Zeile Sachen?
Früher war's Zipper.
Zipper. Immer noch.
Zipper, Install.
Kann man WIM drauf?
Was installieren wir mal? Ähm...
Zipper?
Kann man das Search machen?
Ascii-Quarium.
Gibt's das?
Nee, ist kein Ascii-Quarium.
Das ist schon mal nicht gut.
Was alles in Profiles versteckt?
Ah! Jetzt, das hab ich gesucht.
Hier kannst du auch 3 Milliarden Sachen einstellen.
Okay, kein Ascii-Quarium.
Dann, ein T-Max-Promo.
Ich muss sagen,
die Paketverwaltung geht relativ
zackig. Install.
Wahrscheinlich. Vermute ich mal.
Sudo. Yes.
Also,
fühlt sich schnell an.
Fühlt sich schnell an. Ist okay.
T-Max-Stand. Haben wir denn
den wichtigsten Font?
Super. Search.
Hack-Font.
Sogar installiert, Leute.
Ist sogar installiert.
Okay.
Die haben sogar schon Hack-Default.
Ich glaub's nicht, Leute.
Die haben meinen
Lieblings-Font als Default.
Das ist mir in der Schrift gesagt.
Da haben sie gar nicht aufgefallen.
So, machen wir mal normale Größe.
Ja, das ist eindeutig.
Guck mal, die haben meinen Lieblings-Font
als Default.
Das gibt doch schon mal
Pluspunkte.
Das gibt doch schon mal Pluspunkte.
CNF?
Ist CNF nicht das
Rettet-Installer-Ding?
Warum sollte ich CNF verwenden
für...
Moment, hier oben sagen sie mir,
ich soll CNF zum Installieren verwenden?
Ach nee, DNF.
Ah, nicht. Ja.
Ich hab's durcheinander gebracht.
Früher war es YAM, das konnte man sich noch merken.
Ach nee, das CNF ist Command-Not-Found.
Ach, das ist Command-Not-Found.
Okay, was haben wir denn sonst noch?
Leute, wir machen das mal
wirklich wie die Kack-Noobs über GUI.
Weil ich mal...
Früher war es das zumindest,
was OpenSUSE
mit ausgezeichnet hat,
dass die halt ein ordentliches GUI hatten
für Systemkonfiguration.
Übrigens, das kann man nicht richtig
resizen, doch.
Was halt vielen anderen
Distributionen voraus war für die damalige
Zeit. Mittlerweile
blick ich nicht mehr so durch,
weil ich verwende... Was?
Jaja.
Ich verwende eigentlich kaum
GUI-Konfigurationssachen.
Ähm...
Genau.
Zyperr war besser als YAST schon vor 10 Jahren.
Ja, aber Zyperr konnte man nur installieren, oder?
Über YAST konnte man
früher zumindest auch ganz viel Systemzeug
einstellen. Man konnte irgendwie einen
Samba-Server installieren.
Ich würde es im Leben nicht über einen GUI
konfigurieren normalerweise, aber
es geht.
Aber da hat sich nicht viel getan, muss ich sagen.
Das ganze Zeug ging
vor 10 Jahren auch schon.
Samba-Server konfigurieren...
Man kann YAST 2 mit Cursors verwenden?
Oh, das ist schick.
YAST 2.
Ne.
Ah, nicht Sudo.
YAST 2.
Ohohoho.
Jetzt wird es aber hier richtig
advanced.
Ein Cursors-Interface.
Okay.
Ich wüsste jetzt gar nicht so genau, was
sollte ich hier drinnen jetzt eigentlich machen?
Zum größten Teil brauche ich eigentlich nur den Paket meiner
Sachen installieren. Dann gehe ich in die Konfig-Datei
und mache was drüber.
Fonts Kernel Settings.
Okay, wir gucken mal, was da alles
an aktuellen Sachen dabei ist.
Wir hatten doch irgendwo
so eine
Liste mit Sachen, die wir bei...
Ah, guck mal hier. Linux-Bewertung. Da haben wir es doch noch schon.
Noob-Freundlichkeit Installer
vorinstalliert.
Den Installer
fand ich jetzt easy zu benutzen.
Schön fand ich ihn nicht, aber das muss
ein Installer ja auch nicht unbedingt sein.
Firewall-Pots.
Ja, das können wir tatsächlich mal gucken.
Das machen wir mal mit einem großen YAST auf.
Xast.
YAST. Firewall.
What?
Wow. Oh, das ist mal
unübersichtlich.
Das verstehe ich auch nicht so genau, warum es
kein ordentliches
Firewall-GUI gibt. Es gibt
dieses...
Wie heißt das? GF...
GUFW.
Dieses Mini-Firewall-GUI.
Und ansonsten gibt es so richtige
Uploaded-Dinger. So ordentliche
Firewall-Settings gibt es kaum
was für.
Wie soll denn das jetzt funktionieren,
wenn es fertig ist?
Home.
Was ist, wenn ich einen Port freischalten will?
Okay, wir probieren das jetzt mal.
Also mal angenommen, ich will, dass SSH
eingehend frei ist.
Ah ne, ist schon.
Wie würde ich es denn so machen?
Ich will ja einen Port
einstellen.
Da war ein Tab Ports.
Wo?
Ah!
Ah, verstehe.
Okay,
SSH 22 und jetzt?
Hä?
Auf was bezieht sich das jetzt?
Okay, Add.
Achso, muss ich jetzt sowas hier machen?
Port 22 und dann
Add? Ne.
Ich habe echt legit
keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Ich möchte keinen Schimmer.
Ja, ich weiß nicht.
Wie geht das?
Ich würde jetzt ja erwarten, dass man hier
neue Services anlegen kann oder so.
Accept. Hm, jetzt ist es weg.
Okay.
Ich glaube, da bin ich
einfach zu
zu igui noob
für.
Ist halt Suse.
Okay.
Da steht jetzt Port 22 drin.
Und was genau heißt das jetzt?
Ja, ich will ja keinen Service auswählen.
Ich will einen neuen Service anlegen
beziehungsweise einen Port angeben,
den ich freischalte. Ich weiß, dass SSH 22
schon drin ist. Aber mal angenommen, ich möchte
mal angenommen, ich hätte ein eigenes Programm
auf Port 6321.
Wie kriege
ich das jetzt rein?
Wie kriege ich hier meinen neuen Service?
Einfach alle Ports freigeben.
Das ist natürlich eine tolle Idee.
Interfaces.
Vielleicht kann man hier Ports machen.
Man kann
Sudo konfigurieren? Achso, man kann es einfach so machen.
So wahrscheinlich, welcher User darf und sowas.
Ja, okay, das ergibt Sinn.
Eine Serviceanlege geht natürlich nicht über UI.
Das wäre natürlich ziemlich beknackt.
Einfach Firewall ist eh
overrated.
Achso, wir müssen mal den Browser aufmachen, weil
es ist die beste Firewall, Leute.
Beste Firewall,
die es gibt. Gucken wir uns jetzt an.
Ja.
Sogar die Elektriker-Variante.
Da geht echt
nichts drüber.
Dann ist gar keine Kommunikation mehr möglich.
Eine sicherere Firewall als so
hier in den Knipex.
Es heißt ja tatsächlich Knipex.
Habe ich letztens bei denen auf der Seite
gehört.
Ich dachte
immer, es heißt Knipex.
Aber die selbst sagen, sie heißen Knipex.
Seitenschneider.
Ausstecken. Ausstecken ist aber nicht
secure. Kannst du wieder reinstecken.
Wenn du durchgeschnitten hast, dann kriegst du es nicht wieder zusammen.
Tja.
Gut.
Die Firewall-Settings sind jetzt nicht ganz so
zufriedenstellend.
Wir schieben das einfach mal darauf ab,
dass ich zu dumm bin, das Ganze zu verwenden.
Also, ich habe
eine Anwendung auf Port 6432.
Wie krieg ich das jetzt hinzu?
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Gibt es hier nicht irgendwie einen
Add-Knopf?
Okay, dann bin ich zu dumm für...
Ach, vielleicht müsste ich dann sowas
hier machen.
Kann ich dann da mehrere Ports angeben?
Achso.
Ist das gedacht.
Ja, aber irgendwelche anderen Optionen
dazu kann ich nicht angeben, ne?
Das ist dann wahrscheinlich rein
Input auf was auch immer Home-Zone
ist.
Während man Zonen da jetzt zuordnet,
wann welche
Zone aktiv ist, kann man bestimmt ein Network mal dann schon
machen, ne?
So hässliches UI wie geht, das ist gar nicht so schwer.
Einfach Default-Install
mit
einfach eine KDE oder
ne, ne, ne, ne Dings, was nehmen wir da?
Ja, die Default-Installs
sehen mittlerweile auch ganz brauchbar aus.
IceWM Default-Install
oder sowas, dann wird's
dann wird's eklig.
Ne, hier kann man die Sicherheitszonen jetzt nicht einstellen.
Doch hier, Firewall-Zone!
Ah!
Aha!
Jetzt hab ich's kapiert, wie der Kram funktioniert.
Wow. Was?
Knoppix ist auch eklig,
ja. Ja.
Wird Knoppix überhaupt noch
entwickelt?
Knoppix war früher richtig nice.
LXQD
is ugly as fuck.
Hab ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Was will das jetzt von mir?
Ah, ich soll meinen Passwort-Manager
aufsetzen.
Das ist halt so
eine typische Linux-Geschichte, ja.
Und vor allem so eine KDE-Geschichte.
Es gibt zwar Optionen, aber mal ganz
ernsthaft.
Wenn man jetzt
keine Ahnung hat,
bringt mir diese
Auswahl nix.
Dann würde ich wahrscheinlich GPG nehmen
for better protection.
What?
Das ist Usability pur, die man hier grad wieder
sieht.
Was zur Höhe will das von mir?
Aha, okay. Aber ich kann's
schon mal shaden, das ist schon mal wichtig.
Dass ich's shaden kann.
Hm.
Ich vermute mal, wenn ich jetzt hier Cancel drücke,
darf ich nicht weitermachen, oder?
Ach doch! Ich brauch das gar nicht.
Excellent.
Ich brauch das gar nicht.
Oder ist das jetzt wieder weg?
Nö.
Ich brauch...
Ich brauch das Setting gar nicht, das ist fake.
Except.
Okay, auch gut. Ja, ja, alles weg.
Äh, okay, wie... Wallet.
Was ist, wenn jetzt das Wallet auf
den Passwortmanager?
Das ist halt, das ist so ne typische KDE-Sache.
Drei Spillionen
Optionen, ja?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, was ich machen muss.
Ich weiß noch nicht mal,
wofür ich das Wallet jetzt überhaupt gebraucht hab.
Warum, warum, warum musste ich überhaupt
nen Wallet-Passwort vergeben, wenn ich die
Firewall-Zone an meinem Interface umstelle?
Was hat das eine mit dem anderen zu tun?
Fragen über Fragen.
Ähm...
Okay, schauen wir mal in unsere Bewertungsliste.
Was gucken wir noch her?
Optic Look & Feel.
Ja...
Schwer zu sagen, also...
Es ist halt überladenes KDE.
Wieso fühlt sich deine Maus
unter Linux immer anders an?
Bin absolut neulich.
Ähm...
Ja, weil der Mauszeiger da wahrscheinlich
anders gehandhabt wird als unter Windows.
Ich mein, du bist die Windows, die Fall-Settings gewöhnt.
Sowohl die Standard...
Beschleunigung,
die Standard-Übersetzung von DPI
zu Mausbewegung, zu sonst was.
Das ist halt unter Linux...
ist schlichtweg keine andere Software
drunter.
Wobei, ich muss aber sagen,
also...
Ich hab ja an meinem
Arbeits-Notebook ne MX502.
Nicht, dass ich jetzt Mist erzähle, die fette MX...
MX502?
Ne, äh...
Logitech
G502, nicht MX502.
Also, aber beim Arbeits-Notebook
hab ich ja ne...
So ne Logitech G502 dran.
Also, ich hab da ne recht gute Maus dran.
Und ich muss sagen, also...
Vom Handling her...
Es fühlt sich gut an, also...
Ich könnt jetzt nicht meckern, dass sich der Mauszeiger
großartig schlechter anfühlt.
Und ich hab auch schon öfters mal in der Pause
ein bisschen krunker
gespielt.
Und das ging in den niedrigsten Grafikeigentlichen Settings
auch ziemlich gut.
Aber wir gucken mal kurz, wie gut das in der...
äh...
Wie gut das in der VM funktioniert.
Wahrscheinlich gar nicht, oder?
Ja, sehr schön Firefox.
Accept.
Accept. Ich accepte alles.
Wow!
Spinboard
active.
Ach, du große Scheiße.
Okay.
Die Maus in der VM ist...
Das geht nicht.
Es ist nicht möglich, Leute.
Es ist absolut nicht möglich zu benutzen.
Ähm...
Settings...
Kann die Maus...
Kann es sein, dass man die Mausgeschwindigkeit...
Konnte man echt die Mausgeschwindigkeit nicht?
Oder sehe ich es nur einfach grad nicht?
X und Y...
War das nicht für den Controller?
Ach, ich hab...
Ah, hier.
Okay, wir machen das jetzt mal
ganz runter.
Nee. Nee, Leute.
Das ist schwammig hoch 10, Alter.
Oh, fuck.
Keine...
Nee. Nee.
Das ist in der VM nicht möglich.
Performance ist echt okay.
Kannst dich nicht beschweren.
Ah, du. Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Weg.
Das geht in der VM nicht. Nee, keine Chance.
Das geht in der VM nicht.
Das liegt aber gar nicht so sehr an der Performance
in dem Fall, sondern eher an dem Maus-Input.
Welche VM benutzt du?
Das ist, äh...
Firewall Workstation. So.
Also, look and feel nicht meins.
Es ist KDE.
Freundlichkeit.
Ach, weil es da oben drüber steht.
Es ist KDE. KDE ist...
Es sieht schon verhältnismäßig
hübsch aus, muss man sagen.
Aber...
Nee, schön ist es.
Benutzbar finde ich es nicht.
Es ist eklig irgendwie.
Es ist abartig.
So, Performance-Responsiveness.
Also, sofern man das aus der VM
sagen kann, ist echt gut.
Du hast hier nix.
Also, das fühlt sich flüssig an.
Das Resizen ist
auch trotz 3D-Beschleunigung
echt weich für VM und 3D.
Da kann man nix
Negatives sagen. Die Icons gefallen mir
ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht.
Also, die hier gehen, aber
die...
Aber die
hier Menü-Icons
gefallen mir gar nicht.
Die Elemente stehen viel zu wenig
raus im UI.
Das ist einfach nur Text,
obwohl es ein Button ist.
Und es sieht einfach aus wie Text auf Hintergrund.
Warum?
Warum macht man sowas?
Das ist doch eklig.
Welche Linux-Distrobe gefällst du
für den Alltagsbrauch? Kommt drauf an.
Kennst du dich aus?
Willst du was sehr Konfigurierbares
und was, wo man sich
ein bisschen einarbeiten muss?
Oder willst du was, was einfach installiert wird und funktioniert?
Vielleicht nicht so sehr customizable ist,
aber einfach funktioniert.
Was willst du haben?
Also, wenn du noch relativ neu bist
und einfach was willst, mit dem du arbeiten kannst
und funktioniert, nehm Linux Mint und gut ist.
Als XFCE
oder als Cinnamon oder als
Dings hier. Wobei, Cinnamon würde ich in der VM
nicht verwenden.
Aber dann eben Linux Mint. Da kann man eigentlich
ein wenig falsch machen. Hast du auch sau viele
Hilfen und sonst was
im Internet. Ja, und wenn du wirklich ein bisschen
tiefer einsteigen willst, dann kann ich dir nur Manjaro
empfehlen.
Das neue Ubuntu
kannst du auch nehmen.
Wobei halt
demnächst ein neues Mint rauskommt, was auf Ubuntu
aufsetzt.
distrochooser.de. Den haben wir schon eine
Weile nicht mehr gemacht, ne? Den gucken wir uns jetzt mal
zusammen an. Gut, Gentoo ist natürlich
jetzt nix.
Für Einsteiger
Also, lass dir das jetzt nicht ausschwätzen.
gar nix. Und auch
ehrlich gesagt, für den Alltagssystem,
auch nix.
Ich fand das lustig. Wir hatten
mal einen und der hat richtig
Planertyp, ne? Der ist auch mittlerweile nicht mehr
bei uns. Sprich, der weiß, was gut für ihn
ist.
Der hat Gentoo verwendet
und der hat sich Gentoo erstmal auf seiner
VM installiert und er hat wirklich einen halben
Tag gebraucht, bis das Netzwerkinterface gelaufen
hat.
Weil erst hat er es installiert, dann hat er den
Treiber nicht für das Netzwerkinterface gehabt
und wenn du den Treiber
nicht für das Netzwerkinterface hast, kannst du natürlich auch nichts
nachinstallieren. Der hat irgendwie
dreimal neu installiert, dreimal Kernel neu gemacht,
was auch immer, bis in seiner VM sein
Netzwerkinterface funktioniert hat.
Also, für den alltäglichen Betrieb
ist Gentoo nix.
Und ganz ehrlich gesagt,
meine persönliche Meinung ist, ich wüsste
auch nicht, für was Gentoo
wirklich was ist. Also,
außer man spielt gerne rum und möchte was
lernen, dafür ist Gentoo super,
aber ich wüsste nicht, für wen Gentoo als
Default-System gut ist.
Okay, Starttest.
Was für eine Linux-Distribution soll man nehmen?
Wir machen mal ein bisschen größer.
I want to use Linux daily. Jawohl.
Anonymous Web-Browser ist mir
wurscht.
Game Publisher
scientific purpose wurscht. Proceed.
How would I rate my knowledge about
Computer?
Ja, ich krieg die Sachen
selbst gebacken. Ja gut, ich verdiene
ja seit über 14 Jahren mein Geld mit, also ich kenn
mich damit schon halbwegs aus.
Wobei, das muss man auch mal sagen,
ja. Ich benutze das ja auch gern immer so
als ultimatives Argument, um zu sagen,
ey, Alter, ich kenn mich aus. So, ich verdiene
seit 14 Jahren mein Geld drinne. Das heißt
eigentlich nix. Es gibt so viele
unfähige Leute,
die seit mehr als 14 Jahren
ihr Geld in dem Bereich verdienen und keine Ahnung
haben oder halt einfach Kack-Noob sind, unterm
Strich. Das sagt eigentlich überhaupt nix
aus. How many preferences?
Ähm...
Ich brauch keine Assistenten.
Ne.
Live-Tests? Nö.
Smart-Disk?
Fernseh-Spit-Architecture? Na klar.
Oh, fuck, wie viele kommen da noch?
Ähm...
Ne, Wiki, beste.
Asking other users führt meistens
nur zu sinnlosen Diskussionen.
Wiki, beste.
Windows-like User?
I do not prefer any user interface
style.
Ich will am besten
ne i3 haben.
Das ist weder Mac noch Windows.
Das ist mir vollkommen egal, ob da...
Das ist mir...
Pff...
vollkommen egal, ob die was kostet.
Ich weiß ja eh schon, was ich verwenden würde.
I prefer...
Select.
Ich will die Programme selbst auswählen.
Die Lizenzen gehen mir
persönlich voller Marsch vorbei.
Ich... Nein, das will ich nicht.
Ich installiere alles
selbst. Mal gucken, was da am Ende
rauskommt. Bin ja immer gespannt.
Some distribution may use special features.
Ne.
Brauch ich net.
Ohoho, weder noch?
Paketmanager
ist die beste Erfindung, die sie unter
Lilo überhaupt hatten. Guckt euch mal den Kram unter
Windows an.
Ich brauch nix von anderen Distributionen.
Ich will auch SystemD nicht erwa... nicht, nicht, ähm...
Erwäuden und das muss auch
nicht alles in Containern laufen. Okay, proceed.
Überspringen wir.
Ja, ich weiß, wer Richard...
Richard Stallman ist.
Aber nur, nur weil
der, sagen wir mal, sehr... ähm...
Ja...
übertrieben
pro
reinem
und, und purem
äh, freien und open source
ist, ist es mir immer noch wichtiger, dass einfach der Kram
funktioniert. Also mir ist es
wichtiger, dass der Kram
tut, das können meinetwegen auch ein paar
unfreie Sachen dabei sein.
Wenn ich zum Beispiel Hardware-Decoding
im Browser kriege
und dafür irgendwelche
unfreien Binary-Packages
verwenden muss, mache ich das.
Warum soll ich sein? Warum nicht?
Äh, AppStore brauche ich. Terminal.
Proceed.
I prefer fast updates. Jawohl.
Get Results. Das bin ich mal gespannt.
Was kriege ich? Jawohl!
Ha! Da sind wir richtig.
Da sind wir ja schon.
Ha! Cubes OS.
Habe ja nie was von gehört.
Gentoo.
Binaries können Sicherheitslücken mitbringen. Ja.
Klar.
Nee, mir ist schon klar, was
das alles für Vor- und Nachteile hat.
Aber wie gesagt, wenn ich mir
beispielsweise, wenn ich
mal angenommen, ich möchte Hardware-Decoding haben
im Browser von Videos unter Linux.
Und das würde nur mit dem
offiziellen Chrome in Binary
Variante gehen, weil dort irgendwelche
Lizenzprobleme
dagegen sprechen,
quasi diesen Teil
Open Source irgendwie auszuliefern und so was.
Dann würde ich mir tatsächlich, ich würde mir
Chrome installieren, damit ich
dort beispielsweise Amazon-Video
gucken könnte und Hardware-Decoding
auf YouTube habe. Würde ich, eindeutig würde ich
das machen. Auch wenn es Binary sind.
Ich verwende ja Linux nicht
unbedingt nur aus ideologischen
Gründen, sondern weil es für mich
in vielen Bereichen das angenehmere
System ist. Ich finde es
gut, dass die Sache
zum größten Teil Open Source ist und auch
viel Austausch mit der Community
da ist, was ich nicht schlecht finde.
Aber das ist für mich nichts,
was unbedingt hundertprozentig
immer so sein muss.
Also ich benutze Sachen, ich
bevorzuge Sachen, die funktionieren
vor
irgendwelchen ideologischen Diskussionen.
Also was soll ich benutzen?
Ich soll Gentoo und Arch verwenden.
Okay, ja.
Wir verwenden ja schon Arch
Linux eigentlich indirekt. Manjaro,
ich weiß, die Hardcore-Arch-Leute sagen,
Manjaro ist kein Arch Linux, aber
im Prinzip ist es das doch.
Da sind wir
ja schon. Und mir kann immer noch keiner
erklären, was die Leute
bei Firefox geritten hat, diese komische
Navbar hier rausstechen zu lassen.
Slackware habe ich früher hergenommen.
Slackware ist auch so ein Ding,
habe ich noch nie verwendet.
Ich glaube Slackware ist
die älteste Linux-Distribution
Oh, oh, oh,
KDE-Spaktrum. Ich glaube Slackware
ist die älteste Linux-Distribution,
die es gibt, die noch supported ist, oder?
Wobei Zuzu und Debian
auch nicht weit dahinter sind.
Livestream-Idee, installiere
Gentoo live.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob das so eine gute Idee ist.
Du könntest mal
einen BSD testen, das könnte ich tatsächlich machen.
Meine BSD-Kenntnisse halten sich sehr in Grenzen,
bis auf ein bisschen PFSense.
Oder
compile mein Chrome, das habe ich schon gemacht.
Das dauert halt
nach einem Tag.
Also du kompilierst Linux,
den kompletten Linux-Kernel deutlich.
Und zwar DEUTLICH
schneller
als Chrome.
Chrome braucht, keine Ahnung, 3-4 Stunden
oder so.
Oder
Defugo hat es in 2 Stunden hinbekommen.
Der Kernel ist in 5, 6, 7 Minuten
kompiliert.
Also da
sehen wir schon mal, Chrome ist
eigentlich viel mehr Betriebssystem als Linux.
Zumindest von den Codes
Code-Menge.
Und Komplexität ist Chrome,
Linux da voraus.
Ich habe letztens überlegt,
ob ich nicht mal
WebRTC selbst kompiliere.
Aber ich habe es so eingelassen.
Weil ich wollte unbedingt
die Go-Abhängigkeit aus meiner Video-Überwachungssoftware
rauskriegen.
Weil die verwendet ja immer noch eine Go-WebRTC-Library.
Aber ich habe keine Nerven,
den Kram selbst zu kompilieren.
Ja, genau.
Und du brauchst ordentlich
auch ein bisschen
Disk-Space.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn ich wirklich mal anfangen sollte,
aus irgendwelchen Gründen,
weil angenommen,
man kann Hardware-Video-Decoding
im Chrome nur mit irgendeiner
super
Special-Compile-Flex machen
und ich würde mir wirklich Chrome
selbst kompilieren wollen, dann würde ich
auf DigitalOcean gehen
und mir eine fette
eine fette
64G
16-Core
oder irgendwie sowas
VM holen
und dort mein Chrome drauf basteln.
Das geht richtig geschwind.
Ich habe ja letztens auch
OpenStreetMaps
und
OpenStreetMaps-Routing-Zeug
preprocessen
und processen müssen.
Das ging über die DigitalOcean-VM
richtig gut und zackig.
Und bei mir daheim auf der 8-Core-Kiste mit
nur 48 GB RAM
hat es
Tage gedauert,
weil nicht genug RAM.
Am Ende hat es wie viel? 100G oder so
gebraucht?
100 GB?
Ja, du hast vorhin einen Sub gegiftet gekriegt.
Ich glaube vom...
Wie hat der den Sub gegiftet?
Der hat zwei Subs gegiftet.
Tainsor, oder?
War das?
Da bringe ich es jetzt durcheinander.
Vorher.
Muss ich bei ihm bedanken für
huge, excellent Subscriber.
Gift.
Okay, also wir gucken mal, was bei OpenSUSE noch für
aktuelle Sachen dabei sind.
Äh, wie ist Code?
Okay, guck mal mal, was da für ein Visual Studio Zeug
dabei ist. Standardmäßig.
Zipper. Zipper. Search.
Nach was muss man suchen?
Nein. Code?
Äh...
Kann man Leerzeichen machen?
Da geht's schon los.
Wie finde ich das jetzt?
Gibt beides nicht.
Hast du nicht mal Emotes
bei Fiverr bestellt?
Ich wollte, ich wollte.
Ähm...
Und ich will immer noch.
Okay, dann machen wir das jetzt mal über
Software Center.
Oh guck mal, da gibt's noch eins.
Ist das das Just?
Ist das das Just Software Center?
Oder sind das zwei unterschiedlich
verschiedene?
Okay.
Es gibt schon mal zwei verschiedene Software
Installationsdinger.
Und was hat der jetzt für Schmerzen?
Ah, weil das offen ist.
Okay, es gibt zwei verschiedene Software zum Installieren
von Paketen. Na gut.
Code.
Ich glaube, es gibt kein Visual Studio. Kann das sein?
Es gibt kein Visual Studio
Code.
Na wahrscheinlich, weil das nicht free genug ist.
DeCouts abonniert.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, den zweiten Monat ist es aber nicht.
Den zweiten Monat. Dankeschön.
Huge Sub.
Für den.
Prime Sub.
VS Code gibt's nicht in den Repos.
Ja, sehe ich auch gerade.
Ja...
Wenn es das nicht gibt, ist das natürlich ein bisschen doof.
Aber wir können ja mal gucken.
Ne, gibt's nicht.
Gibt's hier Snap?
Ich bin kein großartiger Snap-Fan,
muss ich ehrlich sagen.
Aber Snap kann man einfach...
Ne.
Gibt's SnapD?
Gibt's auch nicht?
Echt nicht?
Ist ja fast nichts dabei.
Haben wir Chrome dabei?
Chromium. Okay, der ist am Start.
Immerhin.
Ähm...
Ja gut, da gibt's wahrscheinlich auch keinerlei
JetBrains Sachen,
die man aus dem Repo installieren kann.
Oder die Toolbox. Ne.
Okay, das hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert.
Äh...
Qt Creator gibt's den. Den muss es doch geben, oder?
Na, was muss ich denn da suchen?
Wo gibt's den Qt Creator?
Also hier was zu suchen finde ich enorm anstrengend.
Gibt's keinen Qt Creator?
Na, da ist er doch.
Leap Qt 5 Creator.
Gott, da werde ich ja nie drauf kommen, dass das Ding so heißt.
Okay, mal gucken,
wie schnell hier drüber Sachen installiert sind.
Erstmal 30 Milliarden Sachen
nachinstallieren.
Ah, excellent. Die brauchen wir jetzt natürlich für eine IDE.
Irgendwie gefällt
mir das nicht. Irgendwie gefällt mir das eigentlich nicht.
So, dann gucken wir nochmal, was wir für Go
und für Rust
und für Node
Versionen und sowas dabei haben.
Achso, kommen wir .NET
Core installieren.
Wollen wir auch gleich mal kurz gucken.
Nein, nicht .NET.
Ist auch nicht dabei. Vielleicht .NET.
So.
Was für eine Ruby-Version haben wir denn?
2.6, ich glaube,
das ist halbwegs aktuell.
Haben wir einen Docker am Start?
Okay, das Installieren über
Just braucht 3 Jahre.
Ah, Majora's Mask Musik.
Äh,
what? Warum geht...
Mein Tastenbinding für
Scrollen geht nicht.
Das...
What? Warum kann ich im TMAX nicht scrollen?
Steuerung, B,
Bild hoch. Okay.
B?
Nö, geht nicht. Mag nicht.
Gibt's nicht.
Outdated.
Gebated. Overrated.
Scroll not enabled.
Finish.
Der Qt Creator, da ist er.
Der klappt, der sieht genauso kacke aus wie immer,
aber ich finde, einer der besten
CEDs gibt's.
Vor allem, wenn man Qt-Anwendungen machen will.
Ja, oder auch nicht.
Also, normalerweise
geht das mit Bild hoch und Bild runter.
Weil Bild hoch, Bild runter
macht ja genau diesen Escape auch.
Ja, ich
weiß, ich kenn die Dinger, aber geht nicht.
Ich kenn die
TMAX-Defaults, aber der mag nicht.
Steuerung, B,
Bild hoch, Bild runter.
Nein, da geht's scrollen nicht.
Echt doch. Mag nicht.
Ich hab's doch schon mit A probiert, ob die das nicht
standardmäßig umgemappt haben.
Aber gibt's nicht.
Gibt's nicht.
Keine Chance.
Steuerung, B funktioniert nicht,
Leute. Guck mal, ich kann auch nicht
splitten. Warum?
Warum funktioniert meine
Control nicht?
Meine Control-Taste geht nicht.
It's broken.
An sich funktioniert die Control-Taste schon.
Aber
ist das vielleicht eine Sache von diesem Terminal hier?
Dass der
meine Keyboard-Shortcuts frisst?
Der frisst bestimmt meine Keyboard-Shortcuts.
Guck hier.
Der hat grad ganz viel mit Control gemappt.
Okay, ich will das alles wegmachen.
Alles weg.
Ich will alles entmappen.
Wie kann ich alles entmappen?
Lass mich alles entmappen.
Ich will alles entmappen.
Geht nicht.
Ah, KDE. Geh fort.
Gut, das Terminal frisst meine
Control-Keys.
Excellent.
Gucken wir mal, ob wir Docker installiert
kriegen.
CNF.
Try install with.
Ah ja, alles klar.
Ist eigentlich ein Unterschied zwischen ZIP
und Zipper. Gibt es ZIP auch?
Ne. Ja, aber Konsole
frisst das. Konsole frisst das.
Sonst wüsste ich nicht,
warum es nicht
funktioniert.
Ich meine, wir können jetzt mal ganz
ganz fies
sein und wir können jetzt einfach mal sagen
Zipper
Insta Gnome
Terminal
und mal gucken, ob es da funktioniert.
Ne, mit Nixos
habe ich noch nichts gemacht. Hat vorhin schon jemand gefragt.
Ich weiß nicht, das ist dieses Container.
Geht.
Leute, geht.
Das ist Konsole, was die Steuerung key frisst.
Gnome Terminal
geht sofort.
Excellent KDE. Sehr gut gemacht.
Perfekt.
Ähm.
Also, wir wollen einen Docker installieren.
Aber wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Can be found in. Also.
Zipper install
Docker.
Einfach so. Ähm.
Gnome KDE confirmed.
I3 beste.
Ne, offensichtlich habe ich nicht
das Default Tmax Mapping geändert, weil
im Gnome Terminal geht ja das exakt
gleiche Default Tmax Mapping.
Nur irgendwie
frisst die
Konsolenanwendung hier
den Kram. Okay, anscheinend
läuft das auch nicht. Das geht mir
voll auf den Sack, dass ich hier nicht zoomen kann.
Docker ist wahrscheinlich
so eingerichtet, dass das erste Mal
standardmäßig nur als
Root erreichbar ist, denke
ich mal. Ne.
Es ist noch nicht mal standardmäßig gestartet.
Das ist aber
unfertiger Crap, ey.
Machen wir mal so.
Als Root darf ich.
Das ist aber nicht schön.
Hast du schon mal WLAN probiert?
Wir haben es im Stream ausprobiert
mal. Was war denn das da gerade?
Was ist denn das?
Microsoft Rewards?
Oh.
Lass mich in Ruhe, Microsoft.
Die wollen dich aber echt
mit allen Tricks hier
verführen.
Gibt es für Bing benutzen?
Okay, ich habe Bing benutzt.
Bing.
Ja, zum Thema Wayland.
Wir haben es vor zwei Jahren
ausprobiert, hat nichts funktioniert.
Noch nicht mal ordentlich das Rescalen,
das Resizen von
Anwendungen. Und ich
persönlich bin ja auch
der Meinung, dass das mit Wayland
nichts wird.
Ich glaube, es kommt irgendwann
mit den
nötigen, entweder mit den
nötigen
Fanatikern, die dafür
notwendig
sind, was Neues aus dem Boden
zu stampfen und halt auch mal einer, der das
ordentlich managt.
Oder eine größere Firma
macht was Neues. Weil
das ist beides irgendwie so ein bisschen Dead End.
X an sich
klappt ganz gut.
Und der
Support ist halt auch
wunderbar, weil gibt es schon irgendwie
gefühlt 80 Jahre.
Aber niemand möchte neue Sachen
für X machen und niemand möchte X erweitern.
Wayland
ist vom Ansatz her
eigentlich ganz gut gewesen, aber denen ist
irgendwann eingefallen, dass man ja noch
sehr viel mehr neues Zeug einbauen muss,
dass es ordentlich nutzbar ist.
Irgendwie geht es halt sehr schleppend
voran.
Dann haben sie
so die üblichen Diskussionen,
die
gerne in der Linux
und auch in der Open Source Community
geführt werden, so nach dem Motto, wer an was schuld ist.
Zum Beispiel,
ich hoffe, ich kriege das dann halbwegs
zusammen, zum Beispiel diese ganze
VSync-Debatte,
die sie hatten.
Irgendwie hat, ich kriege es nicht
mal richtig aus dem Kopf zusammen. Also wenn nicht
wirklich genau, wieso, müsst ihr mal nachlesen.
Also da ging es irgendwie darum, dass
VSync in Wayland nicht richtig funktioniert hat.
Und dann hat Wayland
gesagt, ja das liegt ja nicht an uns, das liegt an den Anwendungsprogrammierern.
Und dann haben die
hin und her diskutiert und irgendwie
sich jahrelang aneinander abgearbeitet.
Voll für den Arsch.
Und es gibt einen super
Forenbeitrag zu
Wayland.
Ich weiß nicht, wie der hieß da jetzt.
Wayland 2020
Das war ein richtig guter
Forumseintrag.
Das könnte es tatsächlich sein.
Das könnte es tatsächlich sogar sein.
Doch!
Das ist,
das ist glaube ich der Artikel.
Bloß, dass der irgendwie sehr merkwürdig
sehr merkwürdig
formatiert ist.
Ne, das ist der nicht.
Es gab, es gab so,
ich habe letztens einen richtig guten
Foren-Eintrag gesehen, der sich nur mit Wayland
beschäftigt hat.
Und da hat man gesehen, dass
an allen Ecken und Enden noch Baustellen
sind und dass sich das in nächster Zeit nicht durchsetzen wird.
Ja, V-Sync
ist im Arsch.
Das ist halt
das Problem, dass die,
die sind so in der Sackgasse.
Are we Wayland yet?
Das ist eine gute Idee.
So Seiten gibt es ja
ne, gibt es nicht.
Würde mich aber nicht wundern, wenn es die Domain gebe.
Ah, beste.
Beste, ja.
Das ist das falsche Dorf
im Hintergrund.
So, weiter mit dem Wayland-Flame.
Na gut, ähm, zumindest
um die Sache abzuschließen, ähm,
die sind wieder,
die sind in dieser typischen
Linux-Sackgasse.
Also wir haben was
ganz Altes mit X,
was brauchbar funktioniert, aber keiner
mehr ran will. Wir haben was Neues,
was das Ganze ablösen soll, was nicht,
was nicht, äh,
wie sagt man so schön, was nicht in die,
was nicht vorwärtskommt,
richtig, ja, obwohl auch so
eine richtig
geplante, treibende Kraft anscheinend dahinter
ist, dass es mal endlich vorwärtskommt.
Und, ähm, man verliert sich lieber
in Diskussionen, wer gerade
an was schuld ist.
OBS geht nicht auf Wayland. Ja klar, es geht
jetzt auch viel nicht, denn Wayland
war eigentlich mal ne ganz gute Idee.
Ursprünglich. Und dann ist ihnen irgendwann
aufgefallen, fuck, dass wirklich
richtig, dass Anwendungen auch richtig funktionieren
und vor allem halt auch
Anwendungen, die Leute schon seit Jahren nutzen.
Wir können uns nicht erlauben, dass die einfach nicht mehr gehen.
Ähm, daraufhin,
bam, ähm, wir müssen ja
noch 30 Milliarden Sachen einbauen. Fuck, wie machen wir
das?
Gibt's was Neues von Hurt? Keine Ahnung.
Da hab ich schon eben
nicht mehr geguckt.
Also ich geh ja davon aus,
dass, ähm, sie haben's ja,
ich glaub bei Fedora haben sie's ja mal probiert mit
Wayland Default, es könnte sogar sein, dass Wayland immer noch
Default ist, aber man kann relativ easy auf X
switchen. Ähm,
also ich, ich geh davon aus,
ähm,
dass wir nen X
Nachfolger nur bekommen
werden, wenn
jemand Interesse daran hat und
die nötigen Ressourcen mitbringt.
Und dann glaub ich nicht, dass derjenige
hingehen wird und Wayland, äh,
poliert, sondern dass der
was Neues aus dem Boden stampft.
Bei Gnome ist das Default,
das kann überhaupt nicht sein.
Weil Gnome und Wayland erstmal überhaupt nichts
miteinander zu tun haben.
Oder was meinste?
BTFS auch sowas, X4, ja.
BTFS ist ein ähnliches Beispiel,
wobei da vorher im Chat jemand
gesagt hat, ähm,
dass angeblich BTFS
sich jetzt in letzter Zeit immer mehr durchsetzen
würde. Konnte ich so nicht bestätigen.
Entdeckt sich mit meiner Erfahrung nicht.
Manjaro Gnome benutzt X-Hog und
Wayland ist optional.
Ja, wenn man will, dass seine Anwendung
funktionieren, ist Wayland auch, äh, für Crap.
Was auch, was in Wayland glaub ich auch
nicht, gar nicht richtig geht, sind solche Anwendungen,
die, ähm, es nachts
dunkler machen und sowas.
Es gibt ja diese, diese,
heißt das Lux?
D-Lux oder so? Ähm,
was, was quasi nachts den Desktop
dunkler macht, wird er heller und die Farben ein bisschen
ändern. Ich glaube, das geht unter Wayland gar nicht.
Und das sind so Komfortsachen, wo ich mir
denke, Alter, was ist, was ist da
los?
Das, das, das hinkt nicht nur jetzt schon Jahre
hinterher.
Sie sehen das auch nicht ein,
F-Lux genau. Sie sehen das auch nicht
ein und diskutieren und Redshift, ja, richtig.
Und, ähm,
da wird halt, das ist halt so eine typische Linux
Geschichte,
dass sie, dass sie halt gerne
drüber diskutieren, wo
was, wer, wer an was
schuld ist und wo was richtiger ist.
Deswegen geht das in vielen Bereichen auch
nicht vorwärts. Ähm,
Audio ist auch so ein Ding, ja,
das ist,
man hat's ja gesehen,
wenn man sich das anguckt,
unter Android geht der Scheiß ja auch
alles. Aber da hat halt
sich bei Google, hat sich halt Google hingesetzt
und hat gesagt, okay, wir bauen das
jetzt so, dass es für uns gut funktioniert
und wir scheißen auf alles andere
und wir haben Geld
und wir haben Leute und wir machen jetzt.
Da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten,
ob das jetzt
für Linux das Beste ist oder war,
aber es hat funktioniert.
Und da hast du keine Probleme
mit, ähm,
Videodecoding,
oder irgendwelchen anderen komischen Zeug,
wobei unter Android du auch einige Sachen hast,
die fragwürdig sind.
Zum Beispiel,
dass, ähm,
das Zusammenspiel
zwischen Hardware-Decodern und
Browsern
nicht wirklich übergreifend ist.
Also, du hast Tablets,
da funktioniert der Hardware-Decoder
für Videos richtig gut und welche,
die geben irgendwelche Videos einfach random
in Software wieder, weil irgendwie der Decoder
nicht tut. Also, es ist nicht alles, es ist nicht
alles gut. Was, was das angeht,
muss man echt sagen, klappt das
unter Windows und unter
Apple-Geräten am besten.
Der Kram, der tut einfach
zusammen. Wenn du eine halbwegs
aktuelle Grafikkarte hast,
unter Windows, du installierst irgendeinen
x-beliebigen Browser,
also im Prinzip gibt's ja dann nur noch Firefox
oder, oder Chrome-basierte
Sachen. Was anderes ist
ja unter Windows, was willst du großartig
anderes installieren? Einen alten
Edge vielleicht, ähm,
du machst ein YouTube-Video auf
in 16K
oder was auch immer und es wird einfach
Hardware-Decoder abgespielt. Fertig.
Es geht einfach. Unter iOS genauso.
Es geht einfach.
iOS hat noch den riesen Vorteil, dass es halt
äh, Hardware- und Software-mäßig
sehr eingeschränkt ist. Also, die wissen, worauf sie
laufen. Das geht einfach.
So, ähm, also
Docker haben wir Acht drauf. Welche Docker-Version
haben wir da eigentlich jetzt bei, bei Suse?
Version? 1903.
Das ist glaube ich
halbwegs aktuell.
iPads waren bei Tablets schon immer
besser. Ja.
Geb ich dir recht.
Ähm, es kommt ein bisschen drauf
an, was man machen will, aber
rein, oh, das ist sogar, ist sogar aktuell.
Ziemlich aktuell, ja.
Hier von
Ende 2019, ja, geht so.
Ähm, rein
zum, zum Benutzen sind iPads
die besseren Tablets.
Gerade, gerade, gerade
beim Thema Tablets ist Apple einfach
richtig gut. Ähm,
bei Smartphones kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Da gibt's ja welche, die bevorzugen das
eine und welche, die bevorzugen das andere.
Es gab sogar mal zwischenzeitlich
welche, die mochten Windows Phone.
Aber das hat sich jetzt ja
erledigt. Ähm,
aber bei Tablets
ist Apple richtig gut.
Ähm, aber es kommt nach wie vor ein bisschen
auf den Anwendungszweck an.
Wenn man
Sachen braucht, die man
an denen man schön rumbasteln kann,
da sind iPads nicht, nicht das richtige
für. Und ich mein mit rumbasteln jetzt
nicht an der Hardware, sondern ich mein mit
rumbasteln, äh, mit irgendwelchen Automatisierungssachen.
Also wenn du automatisch Sachen
starten willst. Ähm,
zum Beispiel hab ich ja
ein, ein, äh,
Fire,
Fire HD 10.
Zwei Fire HD 10s
neben meiner
Gegensprechanlage für die Tür
hängen.
Und die werden automatisch
mit Display eingeschaltet,
wenn einer klingelt, automatisch
die Software gestartet, die,
die Kamera am Eingang, die Kamera im Hof
zeigt. Das sind so Sachen,
die gehen unter iOS schlicht und ergreifend nicht.
Also solche Bastelsachen,
dafür ist Android super.
Und wo wir wieder mal am Punkt sind, man muss einfach
das nehmen, was für die jeweilige
Anwendungssituation und das was man
machen will am besten ist. Es hat überhaupt
keinen Sinn fanatisch zu sagen, oh nur ich benutze
nur Android, oh ich benutze nur iOS.
Man muss einfach das nehmen, was passt.
Nur die, Windows,
äh, Dennis schreibt, Windows Phone war
schon irgendwie gut, nur fehlten die App-Entwickler.
Ja, das ist so wieder so das übliche
Henne-Ei-Problem. Die User
fehlen und die App-Entwickler fehlen und umgedreht.
Oh, das ist, das ist Wind Waker
Musik, ne? Ah ne, Spirit Tracks.
Fast, fast.
Ja, und ich hab wie gesagt zwei Fire HD 10s
neben, neben meiner Klingel hängen,
neben der Gegensprechanlage. Die gehen automatisch an,
machen die Kameras auf, wär mit iOS so gar nicht möglich
gewesen. Tjo.
Ähm, okay, das haben wir ausprobiert.
Was haben wir sonst noch?
Äh, okay, ein aktuelles Note.
Müssen wir mal gucken, ob da eins drauf ist.
Zyber, Search NoteJS.
Zwölf.
Ein Zwölfer ist drauf. Zwölf. Sogar alles.
Legacy, Zehner und Zwölfer
ist drauf.
Was sollen die, was wollen die eigentlich mit diesem CNF?
Warum macht das das denn nicht für mich?
NoteJS
Common. Okay, was kommt denn da für eine Version mit?
Yes.
Das einzige, was wir
bisher schön an diesem Package Manager
gefällt, der ist relativ geschwind.
Kein Vergleich zu einem
Arch Linux, wo es macht
installiert.
Note 12 ist Default, okay.
Ach, sind die schon bei 14? Ja?
Ist aber noch nicht so lang, oder?
Sind die schon bei 14?
Kann aber nicht so lang sein mit 14.
Ja, seit.
Seit eben.
Seit ein paar Tagen anscheinend.
Ja, seit vorgestern.
Seit heute.
Gut, ich gebe zu, das habe ich
nicht mitbekommen, dass das neue
Note 10 rausgekommen ist.
Äh, mein Stream, der
der hat keine Probleme, ne.
Keinerlei
Probleme.
So, ähm.
Sind wir stehen geblieben.
Gut, den Vue CLI, ehrlich gesagt, können wir uns
schenken.
Gut, die Community
ist bei OpenSUSE, glaube ich, nicht mehr so groß
wie früher.
Gucken wir mal.
Jo.
Ne. Ne, wirklich nicht.
Was sagt denn Reddit Ubuntu?
Na, guckt euch
das mal an. Im Minutentakt
werden hier Posts
aufgemacht.
Und bei OpenSUSE alle
10 Stunden mal einer.
Also Community
mäßig dürfte das auch nicht so der Wahnsinn sein.
Gut, ähm. Ehrlich gesagt,
mir gefällts nicht.
Mir gefällts nicht.
Warum benutzt
du Windows? Dass ich Spiele spielen kann.
Und dass ich meine Videos
machen kann.
Und dass ich ordentlich streamen kann.
Und für alles andere verwende ich meine
Linux VM.
Ne, also, ähm.
OpenSUSE,
also, irgendwie gefällts mir nicht.
Die, die Mischung
aus KDE
und
den zusätzlichen Tools, die man da hat,
ähm, macht für mich
jetzt, ist jetzt
kein Anreiz dabei, das zu verwenden.
Nix für mich.
Ne, gefällts mir nicht.
Was ist denn der große Seller?
Was wollen die uns eigentlich verkaufen?
OpenSUSE. Was sagen sie denn
ist, warum soll man denn OpenSUSE verwenden?
Warum soll man das verwenden?
Das ist viel zu viel Text.
Mediakodex.
Mediakodex hab ich überall mittlerweile.
Ok, ich sehe keinen Grund,
warum ich verwenden sollte.
Ja, gut. Dann
OpenSUSE.
Piss dich, Alte.
Weg. Damit.
Wo hatten wir es denn hin?
E-Doppelpunkt OpenSUSE.
Na.
OpenSUSE. Zack.
Oh, da ist ein Bild,
das mach ich jetzt besser nicht auf. Ich weiß nicht, was da drin ist.
Weg.
Getrackt.
Ne, ne.
Hat mir nicht gefallen.
Ist es das überhaupt noch?
Ist es das noch?
Zu wem gehört denn OpenSUSE
jetzt?
EQT Partners.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Global Investment Organization.
Oh, jojojo. Ok, dann ist vorbei.
RIP.
Was, gleich wieder Manjaro VR?
Was, ich hab meine Manjaro VR gelöscht?
Nein, ich hab OpenSUSE gelöscht.
Ne, ne, ist nix. Also,
irgendwie hat es mir nicht gefallen.
Also,
das hat auch so einen unpolierten
und unfertigen Eindruck gemacht.
Ne.
Echt nicht meins.
So, ich hab mir mal ein paar Sachen
aufgeschrieben, und zwar, dass wir vielleicht
NixOS mal ausprobieren könnten.
Gibt einfach bessere, genau.
Also, dementsprechend gibt es auch für mich keinen Anreiz,
das zu verwenden. NixOS können wir uns
mal angucken. Ich glaube nicht, dass das in alltägliches
Desktop OS, also gut als alltägliches
Desktop OS funktioniert.
Wenn das komplett containerisiert ist,
das habe ich mir mal aufgeschrieben.
Können wir uns das nächste Mal angucken.
Und, ja, das nächste Mal
müssen wir noch einmal
uns tatsächlich mit C++
rumärgern.
Damit wir den Kram auch noch mit WebSockets
fertig kriegen auf dem ESP.
Aber dann ist es auch wieder gut mit C++.
Probier mal FreeBSD.
Ist eigentlich eine gute Idee.
Wir können echt mal ein BSD probieren.
Wobei das eigentlich nix ist,
was ich auf dem Desktop installieren würde, oder?
Ist mittlerweile so
Desktop-mäßig auf
BSD. Wie gesagt, die einzige
Erfahrung, die ich mit BSD habe, ist ein bisschen
mit FreeNAS, aber das verwende ich nicht mehr.
Und
dann
PFSense oder OpenSense.
Was ist SerenityOS?
Sagt mir gar nix.
Serenity
Operation System.
Okay, jetzt schau mal, eine äußerst minimalistische
Seite und ein hübsches
Maskottchen. Das ist doch schon mal was, oder?
Boah, das sieht ja richtig nice
oldschool aus.
Das sieht ja richtig oldschool aus.
Huge.
Und kann man da drauf irgendwas
machen, oder ist das eher so ein
Proof of Concept?
Also anscheinend
kann man da drauf auch was machen.
Das könnte tatsächlich lustig sein.
Okay, man könnte Quake spielen.
Ich schreib mir das mal auf, das ist bestimmt ganz lustig.
Lasst uns doch grad mal
gucken, was sind dann so die
aktuellen GitHub-Trends.
Trending.
Hat aber eine eigene IDE
und einen eigenen Browser entwickelt.
Okay, der Typ, der will es anscheinend echt wissen.
Oh, was ist das?
Was ist das?
Experimental No-Bundle Dev-Server
for VueSFCs
Single... Was sind SFCs?
Components?
Single Components?
Was sind VueSFCs?
Single File Components.
Ach stimmt, ja okay.
Überall 30 Milliarden Abkürzungen.
Okay, und was
genau ist das jetzt? Ich bin ja so der
VueJS-Fanboy.
No-Bundle
Dev-Server for...
Kann ich da...
Kann ich da ohne Webkit einfach
ähm...
meine Components reinhauen
und die laufen einfach, oder wie?
So genau
checke ich noch nicht, was das sein sollte.
Übrigens
eine Sache, die ich auch nicht checke,
jetzt im Javascript-Land.
Im Javascript-Land ist ja gerade wieder ein bisschen
Panik angesagt, und zwar
es gibt ja
NPM, das ist ja der Standard von
Node, der ist ja da schon seit Ewigkeiten dabei
und hat auch so ein paar Sicherheitsprobleme,
wo schon viele drüber geflamed haben.
Zum Beispiel, dass
er Post
Install Scripts und so ausführt.
So,
der neueste Kram war jetzt Yarn,
die sich jetzt
aber selbst in Fuß geschossen haben mit Yarn 2,
was irgendwie inkompatibel zu Yarn 1 ist.
Und jetzt
gibt's als Neues, jetzt gibt's noch NPX.
Und was davon sollte man jetzt nehmen?
NPM, Yarn,
Yarn 2, NPX?
Ich schaffe es nicht, bei
Javascript-Entwicklung Schritt zu halten.
Das ist wirklich
Monka-Monka-Zug.
Du passt eine Woche
mal nicht auf, gibt's 10 neue
Javascript-Frameworks, die hip sind.
Oder
Java-Sachen, die hip sind.
Zu Agile. Dino!
Dino gibt's ja auch noch!
Dino vs. Node.
Was ich bei Dino überhaupt nicht checke,
also
diese, das ist ja, da ist ja Deno.
Deno ist es, genau.
Das ist ja quasi
neue Javascript-Runtime von
einem der Node.js-Entwickler.
Mir erschließt sich
der
Sinn von Deno
erschließt sich mir schon, sie wollen halt ein besseres
Node.js machen, aber was sich mir
nicht erschließt ist
der Anwendungszweck
unterm Strich, weil
Deno kann keine
Node-Packages
verwenden.
Aber verwendet man nicht gerade
Node.js aus dem Grund,
weil es so ein
riesen Paket-Ökosystem gibt?
NPX führt aus,
NPM installt.
Was? Okay.
Aber ich kann ja auch NPM
run machen, wenn es irgendein
in der Config ein Skript
gibt. Ja, ich verwende
auch YAN1, zumindest.
YAN2 ist ja
in Ungnade gefallen, jetzt ein bisschen, weil die Leute
flamen, dass es inkompatibel mit YAN1 ist.
Javascript, echt, hört mal auf.
Da blickst du nicht durch, also
so richtig den Anwendungszweck
von Deno hab ich noch nicht kapiert.
Ich hab mir das auch mal aufgeschrieben, dass wir uns das im Stream angucken.
Aber so hundertprozentig gecheckt
hab ich es noch nicht.
Es ist quasi ein besseres Node.js mit TypeScript Support
drinne und jede Menge netten Sachen.
Aber ohne, dass ich NPM-Pakete
verwenden kann, weiß ich nicht, was ich damit so richtig
machen soll.
Weil der Vorteil von Node.js
ist eben, dass es riesen
massig Milliarden an
Paketen gibt. Auch viele Scheiß-Pakete.
Ja, aber es gibt halt viel.
Python 2 End of Life ist auch ein Drama.
Es ist immer noch ein Drama.
Es kam jetzt die letzte Version raus.
Mit Abschiedsbrief dabei.
Es haben immer noch viele Distributionen
Python 2 standardmäßig verlinkt
in ihren Scripts, warum auch immer.
Irgendwann, ich glaub 10 Jahre haben die jetzt
Python 2 und Python 3 zusammen Support.
Oder 8 Jahre oder so.
Ich glaub 2012 kam das raus.
Irgendwann ist ja mal gut.
Ich versteh's auch nicht so genau,
dass es so ein riesen Drama ist.
Dabei ist doch der Syntax-Unterschied
zwischen Python 3 und 2 gar nicht mal
so groß.
Na gut, also was trendet
noch?
qrcp
Oh, das ist cool!
Transfer Files, Overwrite von mir,
Computer your mobile device by scanning a QR-Code.
Das hab ich schon mal
ausprobiert.
Das hab ich glaube schon mal ausprobiert.
Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Das ist glaube ich nicht so neu.
Das kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor.
Das hab ich glaube ich schon mal ausprobiert.
Aber das
ist enorm praktisch.
Das haben wir schon mal ausprobiert.
Das war cool.
Genau, hier sieht man es.
QR-Code aufmachen.
Scannen.
Zack.
Bild mit Katze am Start.
Was noch nicer wäre, wenn das umgedreht
irgendwie funktionieren würde.
Aber wie soll das funktionieren?
Wir haben ja kein Webcam.
Aber das war cool.
Das haben wir schon mal verwendet.
Vor einer ganzen Weile, aber das hat mir gefallen.
So, was haben wir sonst noch schönes?
Azure Quickstart Templates.
Muss jetzt nicht sein.
Gameboy Emulator in Python.
Okay, Gameboy ist so alt,
den kann man auch in Python emulieren.
Da hat wahrscheinlich ein Gameboy 100%
CPU Last auf dem aktuellen i7.
Und die Strings sind ein großer Unterschied.
Stimmt, ja.
Die haben ja das ganze Unicode Handling
in Python 3 gemacht.
Was ist da jetzt immer mit der 1 in der
Adresszeile?
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen 1 ausgeschrieben.
Da habe ich es erklärt.
How to animate a rotating box using Python.
Nein, das kenne ich nicht.
Kann man das suchen, ohne dass man da
irgendwo gebetet wird?
Was auf Twitter soll ich da suchen?
Auf Twitter suche ich immer ungern.
Da findet man
Katossachen.
Das ist gut.
Das ist echt gut.
Das ist ein guter Witz.
So, was haben wir sonst noch hier?
Irgendwas auf Chinesisch.
Baidu.
Xunlai Vip.
Monai.
AI Toolkit Healthcare Imaging.
Trendet bestimmt im Sinne von
Monka Corona.
Leute, mir fällt etwas ein.
Ich habe am Anfang gesagt, wisst ihr wie bescheuert andere Menschen sind?
Und da habe ich euch gar nicht erzählt, was ich eigentlich erzählen wollte.
Und zwar,
ich war bei mir unterwegs im Ort
und mir ist aufgefallen,
wie wenig Leute in der Lage sind,
eine Atemschutzmaske,
eine normale Maske, so ein Ding hier.
richtig anzuziehen.
Die meisten haben es entweder
um den Hals hängen,
das kann ich noch verstehen, da geht man ins Geschäftsraum
und setzt sie richtig auf.
Aber viele Leute haben die Dinger, die sehe ich aus dem Geschäft rauskommen
und haben sie über den Mund und die Nase guckt raus.
Die Leute sind einfach
dumm und unfähig.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie es die meisten
Leute schaffen zu überleben.
Die sind einfach dämlich.
Und dann auch an so einem Platz
vorbeigelaufen bei uns,
manche kriegen keine Luft,
der soll halt keine Maske aufziehen im Freien,
sondern die Maske nur aufziehen, wenn sie in den Laden reingehen.
Aber wenn du dir die Maske
über den Mund machst,
dann kannst du dir das auch sparen.
So und
da bin ich an einem Platz vorbeigelaufen,
da saßen 15 Leute zusammen
in Anfahrtsreichweite
mit runtergezogenen Masken
und zusammen auf einem Fleck.
Wenn du dich,
ich sage das fast jeden Stream,
aber du bist komplett
verlassen, wenn du auf andere Leute angewiesen bist.
Ja, vielleicht ist das
vielleicht ist das echt
so die, die
so die
Darwin, wir werden
die dummen Leute los.
Keine Ahnung.
So der Darwin Award für die Massen.
In der Schweiz gibt es dafür eine Geldbuße.
Ich glaube, Patrick,
bei uns gibt es dafür auch eine Geldbuße.
Und ich habe auch schon die Polizei rumfahren sehen
und die Juckt das nicht.
Haha, Matt ist natürlich auch nicht schlecht.
Er schreibt, noch besser im Supermarkt
mit Maske, Maske runterziehen, nie
Maske wieder auf. Ja gut, er will eigentlich nicht
in seine Maske rotzen, kann man ja verstehen.
Die Leute sind
einfach so hängen geblieben.
Hängen geblieben, komplett
dumm.
Welches Notebook würdest du zum Programmieren empfehlen?
Irgend eins.
Da gibt es nichts, nichts spezielles,
was ich dir empfehlen kann.
Ja, ich habe euch ja erzählt, mein Nachbar war
und ist ja der Meinung,
Corona ist eine Strafe Gottes
und ich bin mal gespannt.
Demnächst ist ja wieder Ramadan
und er ist ja sehr gläubig, mein Nachbar.
Habe ich jetzt dadurch nochmal
bestätigt bekommen, quasi, dass er daran glaubt,
dass das eine Strafe Gottes ist.
Mal gespannt, wie der das dieses Jahr macht.
Und ob sich wieder der
der Bet-Club da drüben
einfindet, solange man nicht
jeden Tag die Linux-Kanäle kompiliert.
Tja, aber
ich kann ja mit dieser
ganzen
religiösen Theorien eh nichts anfangen,
sagen wir mal so.
Von allen Sachen, die es so gibt,
es wird sich ja immer lustig gemacht,
über irgendwelche Sekten,
oder irgendwie, wen haben wir da noch?
Sind das die Zeugen Jehovas, die glauben,
dass irgendwann die Außerirdischen kommen
und die restlichen Überlebenden abholen?
Irgendwelche sind das doch.
Da kommt, dass die Aliens kommen
und uns abholen.
Oder ist das Scientology?
Das könnte auch Scientology sein.
Irgendwelche glauben, dass das die Aliens kommen
und uns dann retten, oder so.
Und man muss mal
rein
realistisch gesehen,
die Chance,
dass die letzten Überlebenden
der Menschheit
von irgendwelchen Aliens abgeholt
werden,
die ist zumindest,
das ist zumindest möglich.
Die anderen Sachen,
die sind eher im Bereich
der Fantasie, ja?
Das andere könnte mit sehr viel
Zufall ja noch theoretisch irgendwie passieren.
Aber alles andere nicht.
Also wenn man sich überlegt,
dass schon irgendwelche Sekten
logischere Sachen fabrizieren,
als, als
andere...
Da sieht man den Kram, da nimmt sich alles nichts.
Was die Mormonen sind,
dass die mit den Aliens...
Aber das könnte wenigstens noch passieren.
Das ist ja theoretisch noch
möglich.
Dass mal irgendwann Aliens hier vorbeikommen
und die letzten Überlebenden mitnehmen.
Was weiß ich? Das könnte zumindest sein.
Das ist nicht null.
Aber dass ich in den Himmel komme, nur weil ich bete,
die Chancen sind nicht so gut.
Und wenn ich mir überlege, eigentlich ist es doch...
Eigentlich ist es irgendwie
richtig jebaited.
Wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle,
mein Nachbar
glaubt, Corona
ist eine Strafe Gottes.
So.
Und er geht jetzt,
um sich vor Corona zu schützen,
in die Gebetsstunde,
um zu beten,
dass er und seine Familie
kein Corona bekommt.
Und mit 40 Leuten in der Gebetsstunde
fängt er sich Corona ein.
Das ist doch
jebaited, oder?
Das ist dann komplett das Gegenteil
von dem erreicht, was er erreicht wollte.
Ironie vom Fallseher.
Irgendwo schon.
Und wie will er sich das dann erklären?
Das ist die Strafe Gottes, weil er zu viel
gebetet hat, oder was?
Ach, ich hab...
Ich kann damit eh nix anfangen.
Müssen doch geschlossen sein.
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Aber die haben die letzten Jahre über
drüben ab und zu mal
alle zusammen gebetet.
Da kommt dann halt die Verwandtschaft
und da sitzen sie dann mit, frag mir nicht,
15 Leuten im Hof
und beten vor sich hin.
Zum Glück machen sie das jetzt nicht mehr
nach 22 Uhr.
Nachts aus dem Fenster raus,
weil ich pennen wollte und sie haben dann
mit 8 Leuten im Hof gesessen und gebetet.
Meine Güte.
Können ja alle beten, wie sie wollen,
aber so soll ich mich in Ruhe lassen.
Gut, wir gucken jetzt schon noch die Github Trends fertig.
AI Toolkit hatten wir.
Reactive Slack Application
Framework. Das ist wieder so eine
Überschrift von einem Projekt,
wo ich mir nix so richtig drunter vorstellen kann.
Ist das ein Framework, um
Slack Anwendungen zu programmieren?
Slack
Plugins oder sowas?
Ah, doch, da kann ich mir unter der Oberschrift was vorstellen.
Slack
in 2K
Model Serving on
PyTorch
Ok, bei manchen Überschriften
weiß ich echt nicht, was es ist.
PyTorch hört sich nach einem Python Programm an, aber
warum ist das Java?
Bei Github sind sau viele
Forks, aber die Forks tauchen in den
Suchen nicht auf.
PyTorch Machine Learning
Aha.
Das heißt wahrscheinlich...
Ah, ok.
Damit hatte ich noch nix zu tun.
Python in 100 Tagen.
Das ist wahrscheinlich keine schlechte Übung,
vor allem 83.000.
Joyful Pandas
Kann ich mich trauen, das anzuklicken?
Ah, yes.
Excellent.
Alles klar.
Ich mach das.
Track Pick
Ich muss nicht alles aufmachen auf Github.
Monitorrohr
Was?
Das könnte eine Benamung von mir sein.
Wobei ich das Ding
Monitorrohr
nennen würde.
Unified Monitoring
Wallboard Light
Was? Wow!
Ah.
Das ist...
Eine fancy Nagios
Übersicht oder was?
Oder fancy
Zabbix Dashboard
oder was?
Ist das ein Monitoringprogramm oder
füttert man das nur von anderen Monitoringprogrammen
um ein Dashboard zu machen?
Ah, ok.
Och.
Das macht eigentlich keinen schlechten Eindruck.
Ich sag ja schon ganz lange,
dass wir endlich mal
ein simples Monitoring
brauchen.
Man kann mit Zabbix zwar
Gott um die Welt monitoren,
aber für den Heimbereich finde ich
ist Zabbix fast schon Overkill.
Das schreib ich mir mal auf.
Das werde ich mal ausprobieren.
Ob das was taugt.
Das muss ich mir mal angucken.
Was nützt denn ein gutes Monitoringprogramm
wenn du im Monat brauchst es auch nicht zu konfigurieren?
Das ist so die Sache an Zabbix.
Deswegen mag ich ja
diese ganze
Prometheus Geschichte
ziemlich.
Das startest du einfach
und es geht.
Bei Prometheus musst du nicht sonderlich viel machen.
Das startest du und es funktioniert.
POC.
POC-ers.
Petro, was?
Welcher Petro exploitet hier wen?
Ach, das ist
ein
gesammeltes Exploit-Repo
von Petro.
CSS-Only-Library
Es gibt so viel Zeug.
V1
Wow.
Äh.
Warum soll ich das in Hintergrund machen?
Monka.
Hyper S.
Warum soll ich denn sowas in Hintergrund machen?
Meine Güte.
Okay.
Was auch immer.
Vielleicht hat es ja doch seinen Anwendungszweck.
Wenn das 1400 GitHub-Sterne hat.
The world is your green screen.
Ah, yes.
Image-Zeug.
Crawl-Lab.
Okay. Suchmaschinen-Zeug.
Ich glaube, da habe ich
nen Talk zugesehen.
Das war
krass over-engineertes Zeug.
Für irgendwelche super
großen Business-Enterprise-Anwendungen
vielleicht sinnvoll. Aber der
Falls das die Präsentation
ist oder falls das der Konferenztalk ist, den
ich gesehen habe, dann ist das total
total übertrieben.
Falls. Das ist der gewesen.
Naja. Ähm. Der hat
anstatt
die Standard .NET Date-Time
Klasse zu verwenden, hat er sich
ein .NET
Date-Time Interface vorher gemacht,
dass er nicht mehr abhängig
ist von der .NET Date-Time
Klasse. Als würde er die jemals im
Leben austauschen.
Also man kann es echt mit
Abstraktion auch total übertreiben.
Vielleicht für super
große Enterprise-Business-Dinger
meinetwegen.
Das ist genauso wie den
Konferenztalk, den ich mal von irgendeinem
Ruby-Pro gesehen habe. Der hat auf der
Bühne gestartet und hat gemeint, so hier
er zeigt jetzt mal ein bisschen Ruby-Magic
und hat dann erzählt, ja also hier
das sind alles für ihn ganz ganz
starke Indizien für das hier was nicht
stimmt im Code. Sind alles Code-Smells.
Code-Smells. Und dann hat der Typ
gesagt in seiner Präsentation
Leute wisst ihr, ab wann für
mich eine Ruby-Funktion
beziehungsweise Ruby-Methode, ab wann das
ein Code-Smell ist?
Habe ich so
für mich überlegt, ja gut, kommt
auf die Funktion an, kommt drauf an
was die alles aufruft, sonst was.
So 50 Zeile
wird es vielleicht ein bisschen unübersichtlich und so.
Und dann meinte der ernsthaft,
ernsthaft, in der Präsentation
mehr als eine Zeile.
Habe ich mir gedacht, wie, da besteht
ja sein Code nur aus Funktionen.
Wie soll das denn
funktionieren? Wie will der dann ordentlich
wie will der dann ordentliche Funktionen programmieren,
wenn er pro Methode und pro Funktion nur
eine Zeile programmieren darf?
Wie soll das denn funktionieren?
Also manchmal wird
auf Präsentationen, also auf Konferenztalks
wird auch schon viel Bullshit
erzählt, weil der Tag lang ist.
Warum mag aktuell
keiner mehr IDEs und jeder mag VSCode?
Das stimmt, würde ich so gar nicht
unterschreiben. VSCode
ist beliebt, gerade in den Bereichen, wo es keine
ordentliche IDE für gibt.
Oder die IDEs zu teuer sind, wie auch immer.
Ich meine, was gibt es denn für
eine Alternative,
sagen wir mal, zu
wenn du Arduino Zeug
machen willst. Da gibt es nichts gescheites.
Da gibt es die Arduino IDE, die suckt.
Oder Platform.io
unter VSCode. Wenn du ordentlich
JavaScript,
Vue.js,
CSS, HTML Zeug machen willst,
in Kombination
und gerade mit den
der Fülle an Plugins gibt es da
eigentlich auch nicht viel Konkurrenzfähiges.
Es gibt noch WebStorm, der kostet
aber was.
Hat mich jetzt auch nicht so überzeugt beim ausprobieren.
Programmierst du heute noch?
Ne, ich gehe gleich ins Bett.
Programmiert wird wahrscheinlich morgen oder übermorgen.
Notepad++
ist, man glaubt es gar nicht, immer noch
ziemlich beliebt.
Ok, sehr viel China Zeug
hier noch.
Loki, like Prometheus, but for
Logs. Das habe ich mal
auch auf irgendeinem Talk gesehen.
Habe ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Weiß gar nicht, ob sich das lohnt.
Kubernetes. Na, dass das Stars kriegt,
ist schon mal klar. Das ist ja das Trend
Trend-Ding und Bullshit-Bingo-Ding
zur Zeit schlechthin.
Distributed Database in Java.
Nein. GoCleanA.
Arsch.
Da wüsste ich schon mal überhaupt nicht, was es sein soll.
Wahrscheinlich Beispiele, wie man
saubere Go-Sachen
programmiert.
Da war jetzt nicht so viel Gutes,
dabei, was... Today.
Was trendet denn diese Woche?
Avataify.
Benamung 6.
Das irritiert mich übelst.
Die
lacht so ein bisschen.
Bisschen Kappa-Style.
Das irritiert mich voll jetzt.
Das irritiert mich.
Avatars for Zoom and Skype.
Ok, das speichere ich mir mal.
Kein cooles Projekt zu sein.
View Next.
Müsste demnächst rauskommen.
Da bin ich echt gespannt drauf.
Ich so als alter Vue.js-Fanboy.
Noch mehr Corona.
Oh, Leute, das ist doch was für uns, oder?
Endlich.
Excellent.
Ein Kobol-Kurs.
Den machen wir zusammen
im Stream, Leute.
Wir lernen Kobol.
Wir machen einen Kobol-Programmierkurs
zusammen.
Ich habe das jetzt eigentlich nur als Witz gesagt.
Aber ich glaube,
das wäre echt lustig.
Wir lernen das nicht von Anfang bis Ende.
Wir gucken uns das mal 3-4 Stunden an.
Das reicht.
Das, glaube ich, machen wir echt.
Ich glaube, wir machen
wirklich einen Kobol-Kurs.
Das wird lustig.
Morgen Abend ist Kobol-Time.
Kobol-Time.
Kobol.
Kannst du den Link kurz mal schicken?
Kann ich nicht machen.
Das wird eklig, Leute. Ich sage es euch.
Das wird richtig eklig.
Chapters.
Oh, es gibt schon mal eine Vue.js-Code-Extension.
Das ist gut.
Basics, Kobol.
Hallo?
Wie macht man das überhaupt auf?
Ah, man zoomt runter.
Oh je, Leute.
Ich ahne Schlimmes.
MonkaS.
Oioioioi.
Oh ne.
Wir haben
auf der Arbeit so ein Austauschprogramm.
Da kann man sich dafür
bewerben. Wir nennen es mal bewerben.
Man muss es nicht großartig machen, außer sagen,
dass man es haben will.
Dass man mal in eine andere Abteilung gehen kann.
Oder in ein anderes Team gehen kann für eine Woche.
Das mache ich.
Da lerne ich hier Kobol.
Und dann gehe ich eine Woche
zu den Mainframe-Leuten.
Und dann
und dann hackte ich in Kobol.
Und dann werden sie alle in WTF.
Dann werden sie alle sagen WTF.
Der Max soll bei uns anfangen als Kobol-Programmierer.
Und dann kriege ich 8 Spillionen
im Jahr.
Weil ich der Einzige bin, der noch Kobol kann.
So machen wir das.
Das ist der Plan.
Decentralized privacy preserving
proximity tracing.
Boah, was ein Name.
Decentralized
privacy preserving
proximity tracing.
Der Corona-Tracker.
Baidu. China-Kram.
Was? Virtual Machines
for iOS?
Moment. Was ist das?
Was ist das?
Kannst du auch Assembler?
Können ist...
Können kann man das nicht nehmen.
Wir haben hier im Stream schon ein bisschen rum
gespielt.
Auf dem ESP32.
Geht das echt?
Wie installiert man das?
Gibt es da eine App?
Ah, das muss man über den alten...
Das kann man nicht über den richtigen App-Store installieren.
Hehe.
Aber das ist ja cool.
Fucking Algorithm.
Sehr gut.
Moin, Mr. Price.
Real-Time-Voice-Cloning.
Ich finde das echt wirklich
extrem cool, wie viele
neue Machine Learning
Sachen, das ist gar kein Machine Learning Projekt,
vor allem weil es Python ist,
rauskommen mit Sachen,
wo man sich noch vor
fünf Jahren gedacht hat, das werden wir
in nächster Zeit oder das werden wir vielleicht nie mit
Computer machen. Also da tut sich sehr
viel auf dem Bereich.
Go-Admin.
Wie viel plus Element URL?
Was?
Flutter-Kurse.
Ja, Flutter müssen wir auch noch ein bisschen
lernen im Stream.
Wollte ich nämlich mal mich ein bisschen
genau machen.
RTX-Voice habe ich schon gesehen, ja.
Ist auch sehr cool.
Ach, guck mal.
Das ist die Web-RTC-Library, die ich in meinem Video
Überwachungs-Dings verwende.
Die ich eigentlich loswerden
will, weil ich...
Die einzige Sache, die ich in...
Warum ich neben .NET noch Go verwende, ist diese
Library, weil es nichts Vergleichbares gibt
in keiner anderen Sprache.
Und der Interop mit Go
ist halt Cancer.
Go funktioniert nur mit
gut, mit sonst nix.
Und nachdem ich FFmpeg für die Streams brauche...
Ja.
Passt halt nicht zusammen.
Free-and-Open-Source-Manga-Reader für Android.
Den hat da Sebarro bestimmt auch.
ES-PILD.
Moment.
Boah, guck mal, jetzt werden sie
aber hier richtig Meta.
Jetzt kannst du JavaScript bundeln
mit Go.
Nice. Moin Prophet.
Ich vermisse Battlefield 3,
sagt er. Ja, ich vermisse auch Battlefield 3.
Also, ich vermisse
den Game im Sinne,
im Geiste von Battlefield 3.
In welcher Sprache hast du dein Memeboard
geschrieben? Das ist rein...
rein Windows-only
.NET, noch
altes .NET Framework, noch nicht mal .NET Core.
Das ist
Windows-only
.NET Framework C-Sharp.
Leute, schön, dass ihr dabei
wart.
Ich muss jetzt pennen.
Morgen muss ich ja nochmal arbeiten.
Dann ist Wochenende.
Denkst du, das neue Battlefield 6, so wie die alten Battlefields,
wenn Battlefield 6 noch nicht mal angekündigt und ich glaube
nicht, dass sie es hinkriegen.
Leider.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns.
Ich hoffe morgen und
ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir uns wirklich Kobold geben
morgen.
Schauen wir mal. Macht's gut.
Bis dann. See you.